[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
n
he
[Music]
pap
he
[Music]
Bo
ahahahahahahahahah
he's down a piece he's down two pawns a
couple of checks magnus's King is going
to dance easily out of them take my
queen and give me a new one please he's
losing now he walks right into the and
they know it they know it turn your
boards I know 9 952 made a big mistake
oh and the bar's going up this is an
absolute Gem of a game Wesley saw has
done it he's going in for the attack but
he's walked into Checkmate black can
play Rook takes
porn one move Checkmate two seconds oh
my God what an arm get
in we've had the planes we've had the
placement and we have our eight players
for the chessable Masters welcome
everyone I'm International Master T sat
alongside me my two good friends grandm
Robert H and grandm David how Robert
David I missed you guys we have a new
year a new season a new format and
Robert you have a new pink
chair I certainly do and I am jumping
with excitement because as you said the
play-ins the placements they were super
exciting but here we go we have lift off
it is the KO
today yeah I've missed you guys I've got
to say I've missed the players it feels
like just yesterday it was the tour
finals out in Toronto 2023 but we're
back hopefully with a bang I can't wait
I've been watching the last two days
with so much uh excitement and it feels
like things are only going to build from
this point on time flies David and time
will fly in this format as well because
the players will be playing with just 10
minutes and a 2C increment but also just
four regular events in this season of
the Champions Chester let's take a look
at our tour schedule so you guys can
mark your calendars we've got the first
event the chessable Masters the second
one starts on May 8th the third one will
be in July and the final fourth
qualifying event for the season and
final with will be in September we will
have our first finalist with the
chessable Masters but Robert it's not
the only part to the season and final no
it certainly isn't because the winners
of each and every event they move
through to the final but so do the other
players on the leaderboard so if you
don't win you better perform well
because you can still earn your way
through to the December finals yeah it
might be early in this new 2024 season
but there's so much at stake we saw it a
lot of the best in the world already
entering those playerss they're hungry
they want to score the maximum they can
from every single event so it's going to
be a long season a fun season but plenty
at stake already and uh we're only just
starting yeah it's going to be a fun
season and the fun has started but the
fireworks happen already already as uh
well Magnus Maxim and fedos will join
the arena today but five players had a
hardfought battle to make it to division
one of the chass bable Masters and as
Daniel would say damn girl we had some
big
upsets it's day two of the cheser Bol
Masters the 2024 Champions chess tour is
officially underway against AAR Nakamura
that Rook on H6 is ugly AF no that's it
B4 what a result two Z yep and he done
it sacrifices The Rook that is a heads
up play Peter fidler's division one
hopes come to an end is our first round
of match play in the books that's how
you have it wow
somehow he was able to win and he's
about to Checkmate Sam sevian Queen E1
he wins the match claps his hands
together he gave a little bit of a dance
there was that a little so Stutter Step
the so swing I don't know what that was
if you play Queen F6 Bishop G7 uh all I
need is a draw bro and there's the guy
who continues to have an amazing
chessable Masters fuia doesn't miss
exchange sacks very often he loves
himself a good exchange sack and we get
the brilliant
symbol
wow always a little
nerve-wracking always a little
nerve-wracking look at Anish he's doing
his best Dennis lazic the kid sends home
hikaro Nakamura notom sends him to D2
Anish giri will join his fellow 2800
Club member are we looking at a future
member of the 2800 Club Dennis lazovic
gets the job done draws with
black danis the Menace Strikes Again we
saw phenomenal performance by the
17-year-old in the last season when he
made it to Toronto to the finals and
what a start he's had to season of 2024
we're ready to kick off division one and
let's take a look at our bracket the
dramatic matchups that are coming up
between our eight division one players
we've got some heavy weights we've got
some surprise names David which matchup
stands out to you wow they're all so
juicy Tanya I can't wait to see how
Dennis lazic continues his run after
scoring those upset wins yesterday over
Nakamura and giri but my eyes are drawn
slightly lower down the screen Magnus
Carlson enters the frey our world number
one and he faces off against Wesley so a
repeat of those grand tour finals the uh
season finale in 2023 Wesley so there
did fall to defeat can he get his
revenge that's the big
question a garage match for Wesley so
this has become the L Classico of the
Champions Chester and once again we see
Magnus Carlson take on Wesley in their
very first match up but it's not just
that as you mentioned David we've also
got Maxim taking on Dennis lawick and
these two have a big story line as well
but we're going to focus on our mocky
matchup Robert we've seen a Magnus take
on Wesley so many times but the last
time they played each other it was a
Magnus Carlson show it was indeed
because Magnus Carlson triumphed on the
very big stage of the CCT finals in
Toronto so Magnus he's always the
favorite when he's in the event
head-to-head against Wesley big margins
in magnus's favor so it's hard not to
think that Magnus is ahead in this
however Wesley we know when he's at his
best he can even take down the world
number one yeah and Magnus will start as
the favorite of course but Wesley he
scored 19 wins in Rapid that's more than
most people can dream of achieving
against Magnus in their lifetimes and
Wesley has the added bonus of having
warmed up over the last couple of days
Magnus he's coming in uh to this event
cold uh he hasn't been involved in those
play and I have a sneaky feeling that
that extra match practice might well
favor Wesley so we'll see everything up
the grabs of course but this is the man
to beat Magnus
Carson yes and we know one thing about
Magnus very often he tends to start slow
in these tournaments and then picks up
the PA he becomes unbeatable at some
point but right now it is the first day
that Magnus gets on the board gets into
action can Wesley strike early on it is
going to be his big chance to get that
Grudge wict Tree in a big big day coming
up for these two in the winners
quarterfinals Robert what are the big
takeaways for Wesley to make sure that
we don't have a repeat storyline from
Toronto I like what David just said that
Wesley is warmed up that practice
certainly helps because it's not like
he's playing anyone out there he is
playing World Class Grand Masters he
earned his spot to today's action so I
do think that Wesley he needs to forget
that it's Magus Carlson history may not
repeat itself and the history that
Wesley does want to repeat is that
fisher random world championship match
where Wesley didn't just beat Magnus he
destroyed
him yeah absolutely and that's not the
only big fight we've got four matches
and the other one that we're all very
excited about is Dennis lazovic taking
on the Frenchman Maxim Vel gr now these
two also played against each other in
the Toronto finals it was the one big
match victory for the young Dennis
lazovic and and what a performance that
was taking it in the Armageddon against
Maxim and we see their score line here
with two draws these were the draws that
happened in Toronto in their rapid and
then finally Dennis getting the dub done
in the Armageddon is that going to be
the match strategy for Dennis today as
well David uh quite possibly I think he
wouldn't be averse to taking this to
Armageddon a one-off kind of shootout
for the victory but Maxim Vash gra I
don't think he wants to let it go that
far it's been a while now since the top
players stopped underestimating Dennis
Dennis is just a great player they all
know that so Maxim will need to bring
his a game I think he might try to hit
Dennis in the opening where still
compared to hit the slightly older
players uh more predictable but uh this
one is anyone's game I think it's a real
50-50 Dennis lazic is the super GM
Slayer just to get to the division one
winners bracket he beat Hikaru Nakamura
and not just that he took down Anish
giri right after so Dennis lazic he has
what it Tak takes absolute monster in
just 17 years
old it's not about the size of the dog
in the fight it's about the size of the
fight in the dog and Dennis lasic has
made it clear he's not going to get
bullied he's going to bring on the fight
he's already
relegated Hikaru Nakamura and Anish giri
can he do the same against Maxim Vella
gra today let's take a look at the
format of our division one knockout
stages it is a double elimination
bracket it's fast and furious as the
time control is just 10 minutes with a
two second increment with every move two
and a half points gets you the match
victory in case of a tie we will have
the bidding Armageddon the loser goes
down to the losers bracket the winner
continues to stay on the top in the
winners bracket and the big thing to
remember in this season for all of us is
four events we will have eight players
to make it to the finals the four
winners from the four events and from
the tour standings the time format Chang
as we saw with 10 minutes and a two
second increment and for all the other
details about the changes in this year's
Champions chest we've got Danny breaking
it down for
us every Champions chess Tour event
kicks off with a playin tournament
followed by match play on the second day
to determine placement across divisions
1 2 and three the remaining players then
compete in these three divisions across
6 days of grueling yet thrilling double
elimination knockout chess all players
are battling to earn their chunk of the
$300,000 prize fund and Tour leaderboard
points but the biggest prize is a spot
directly to the live finals at the end
of the year only the winner of division
1 will claim that honor in addition they
and the runner up both secure re-entry
to the top division our next time around
the winner of division 2 also secures a
spot in division 1 while the winner of
division 3 is guaranteed at least a seat
in division 2 and may even advance to
division divion one through match play 8
days three divisions one golden ticket
to the Champions chess Tour live finals
this is the chessel
[Music]
Masters the first golden ticket is up
for grabs in this one and the fight
starts in just a couple of minutes you
got four juicy matchups and one of the
players who also made it to division one
Ali RZA fuja now he had a disappointing
Toronto finals he's definitely looking
for a better performance uh this year in
the Champions chess store what are we
expecting from Ali RZA and what did you
make of his performance in the
placements yeah I've got to say ala I
was quite impressed throughout the
placements it felt like uh okay he's not
quite in top form he's moving through
the gears but he was always there or
thereabouts and uh when the chips were
down when it mattered he made his Mark
and that's been the story of uh the last
12 months for aaser up and down his year
his rating in tataa steel it was up and
down lots of wins but lots of losses as
well so it's entertaining for us we're
loving it as commentators but he'll want
a calmer progression of course through
these knockout rounds um I want to see
ala on his aame Happy Days for Ali Raza
because yesterday he defeated vladislav
artv and we know how dangerous artv can
be and so can his opponent Vladimir foso
I don't think that anyone wants to face
the big fish because he's taken down the
likes of the very best players on the
planet this is a pretty epic
Clash the big fish in division one sorry
David I'm I'm just loving those
fashionable and victorious big fish in a
big pond uh these players just loving
those nicknames and I wanted to ask you
guys we now know the eight uh eight
finalists I'm going to say in division
one who in division one do you think is
going to take that golden
ticket putting you on the
spot I'm waiting for
you gosh it's hard to bet against this
guy called Magnus Carlson you know I
mean I don't know if you guys have heard
about him if you know him I mean he is
uh the he won three events in Champions
chesta 2023 he is a three-time and
riging tour Champion he is the world
number one he's always eating on camera
it always looks like he's just woken up
his hair is all over the place but his
chest oh my God always on point it
certainly is and look at Magnus right
now as you said it it does seem like he
may have just woken up he's wearing a
pretty fashionable shirt and we'll see
if his chest is up to par with how he
has played in the past because I think
David's point from earlier is a very
good one that even for Magnus he can be
a bit slow to wake up on the chess board
it sometimes takes a few games to get
your feet beneath you so for Magnus you
don't have the luxury of time when
you're playing Westley so because if
Wesley can win the first game it's
really hard to beat that guy he is one
of the most solid players in the planet
yeah and I do know that Magnus has more
tournaments lined up his next tournament
is Fisher random freestyle chess I know
he's been focusing on that a lot so this
might be the time to strike him when his
attention has strayed perhaps when he's
not quite warmed up yet and uh yeah of
course Magnus he's going to be the
favorite good choice Tanya but I think
we might see a surprise at least on this
first
day well when you play Super Grand
Masters you better be warmed up and we
were mentioning how Dennis lazic he beat
hiar and an nishe yesterday just to make
it to division one look at how
underrated this kid is I call him Dennis
the Menace and for good reason because
his rating may be 2550 at least on paper
but look at these results on a world
class stage in the world rapid in 2022
2667 performance then the world Blitz
right after that
2764 in the 2023 World rapid 2621 the
2023 World Blitz 2693 he is performing
over 2700 in the quickest of time
patrols and of course in the CCT finals
in Toronto he didn't make it through but
he beat Maxim Basher lra head-to-head
still perform about 2650 so it is very
clear that his ratings should be thrown
out the window because he is always
overperforming his ratings have not
caught up to his strength you relegate
Hikari Nakamura you relegate Anish giri
everyone's taking you seriously in this
event Dennis lavic was so impressive in
last season and we often spoke about his
style of play which is so different from
his colleagues and his contemporaries
from The Young under 20 generation right
now we see him play these strategic
positions we see him fight it out dual
it out in these long end games he
manages to hold against the very best
when he gets that opportunity he strikes
in it he has that patience and that's
what makes him so different David what
do you think is the reason we see him go
in the long run against the very best in
the world is it the style of play that
we've been talking about yeah Dennis
Lazar Vicious he's uh just he's got this
confidence that uh kind of belies his
young age he yeah he really kind of
believes in his ability to handle these
end games these long grinds and his
opening repertoire so finely honed
everything you need in Rapid chess in
speed chess Dennis lavic has it nerves
of Steel fantastic openings and uh that
confidence to pounce when even the best
players in the world are facing him uh
any small mistake he's ready to strike
so the question is whether Dennis will
be lazza victorious in his uh in his
Clash today but in the meantime we see
Wesley so getting ready for that match
against Magnus Carson so many games and
we'll try to follow them all and I think
Wesley so is walking around right now in
his playing room trying to figure out
where to put that second fair play
camera we saw him moving around with his
laptop and there he is uh still confused
about how to make the logistics work I
have to say I was following the the
placement action and Wesley situation
with the two chairs his laptop on uh one
of the chairs it was surprising to say
the least but it didn't it did not
affect his Chess at all well a part of
the fair play monitoring is showing that
there's no one else in your room that
everything is under control and when we
had Wesley so on camera there I saw in
the background he had like a rook and a
knight on his shelf and there's Wesley
he's got a blanket he's he's not just
warmed up from yesterday's action but he
is warm and ready because he's under the
comfort of that security blanket so for
Wesley so he looks like he's ready to
play but as we saw behind him there's a
knight there's a rook and maybe he's the
king after
all Wesley looks warm he needs to get
the hot chess going against Magnus
Carlson you mentioned that he looks
secure in that blanket Magnus mentioned
a really interesting thing David after
that victory in Toronto uh that he sort
of plays against Wesley style sort of
the lack of aggression in Wesley and is
Wesley bobbing to some music some tunes
there yeah wesy are we going to see more
aggression Wesley had something in his
ears maybe it doesn't sound like the
most aggressive of Music uh the most
upbeat Tunes there it looks like a calm
slow Melody he looks very chilled so
chilled W Le so there but in the
meantime I agree he has to be aggressive
on the chessboard he has to uh kind of
knock back down not let Magnus dictate
the pace the nature the style of the
game and not let Magnus bully him
psychologically which uh you know we've
seen so many times from the world number
one Magnus lives rentree in most of our
heads he just has to ensure Wesley that
that doesn't happen today uh but we're
almost at game time we're almost off
we're awaiting the first moose Magnus
starts with white any predictions with
the opening before it's too late oh it
looks like the Rey he got there
first yeah we didn't have a chance to
put in our guesses but I think Magnus
then the lights are out at least over
his face so he needs to work on that
camera angle but hopefully the lights
are on upstairs in his head oh and there
we go he takes that drink of water and
what do you make of the opening Tanya
where Magnus he hasn't decided to create
tension the center at least not yet do
you like this sort of Cy start from him
well we see him do this quite often but
against Wesley it's usually been the
start with the King spawn opening or the
Queen spawn opening at least that's what
we saw traditionally in the Champions
chest do so a new approach but with
Wesley Speed that he's resp bonded with
he doesn't look or at least he's not
acting to be too surprised with this and
now it's the big decision how does
Wesley keep the tension in the center
here Rob ITT well he decides instead of
to keep the tension he is trying to
avoid it for now David Magnus strikes
with B4 so he is trying to Chisel at
Black's Pawn chain and it is a pawn
sacrifice what do you make of this mini
Gambit yeah um I've got to say I like it
but I also hate it firstly you're a porn
down so not the not not my cup of tea
not the uh kind of favorite approach by
many top players these days you don't
want to be too uh kind of materialistic
in general but here Magnus his idea was
to open up as many lines as possible and
Robert you mentioned it's kind of a
flank Gambit it's basically a reversed
version of the Beno Gambit as we call it
but Wesley has said no he bypassed this
Pawn if Wesley earlier had captured on
the A3 Square then White's Rook would
have opened up on the a file there would
have been open lines here for the white
Rook White's Bishop would have come out
so interesting that Wesley could have
been a pawn up he did he is temporarily
but this Pawn will soon fall and uh I
don't know have you either of you two
got experience in the Beno Gambit I must
say not my era of
expertise no I've actually played this
position with the white pieces where
white pushes the B5 bar from B5 to B6
and gives that bar back but again to me
this feels like a KGI approach from
Wesley trying to keep things secure like
his blanket that he's got on right now
but then again this is the kind of stuff
that can backfire against Magnus rob
butt does this surprise you that Wesley
decided not to capture that A3 Pawn well
this entire opening has surprised me and
even magnus's last move pushing his Pawn
to A4 rather than recapturing on B3 both
sides are trying to lay claim to
important space in squares the B4 Square
for black is now firmly under control
and then for white you have this light
Square diagonal the bishop on G2 is
unopposed on that diagonal and so we
could see that Bishop shining its powers
across the board I don't know whose
position I'd rather have it's a new
position to my eyes but it feels like
one where both players are on their own
yeah it feels like both players have
Trump cards uh up their sleeve uh you
mentioned the B4 Square white night also
has access to a beautiful outpost on B5
a bit later first Magnus wins the porn
back and uh Tanya from your experience
you mentioned you've kind of played this
opening just with reverse colors um do
you think Magnus is going to be happy
here he's basically played an opening
you usually see with black but he's
white so he's got an extra Tempo should
he be happy about that and it's always
tricky to kind of adjust yourself to
these reverse colors opening one of the
ideas as white that I like in this and
that would mean a position that black
has currently for Wesley is to actually
transfer that knight from F6 to the C5
Square we've been talking about how
important these squares are so there's
often this plan of the Knight falling
back and then finding itself on C5 which
is a nice quare I think at Le he was
perhaps expecting a more Dynamic
approach by Wesley to capture that A3
Pawn to pick up that Free Pawn which
gives a lot of activity to White uh and
now he has to fight in this position I
like these positions uh well in this
case for white uh sorry for for black
hair simply because that knight from F6
will land on the square of C5 which is a
nice square and I'm getting confused as
a commentator with reverse colors I have
no idea how the players are handling it
and I I actually found that funny
because I'm doing the same thing in my
head because it is a b Gambit colors
revers and we saw for a quick moment
this bishop B4 move from Wesley perhaps
the most natural move developing your
piece getting ready to Castle putting on
defended Square the engine didn't really
approve it and I think it's precisely
because of what Magnus is doing he can
challenge this bishop immediately and if
white takes on B4 next move that Knight
on C6 could not capture back which is
why Wesley right now brings his Knight
back to D7 that way the E5 Pawn is well
protected and if a capture on B4 happens
he can successfully take back with a
knight rather than doubling his pawns
which you may want to do in some
positions but here I'm not so
sure yeah it feels like this is uh the
two players just tiptoeing around each
other Magnus makes that decision he
trades off the Bishops and uh yeah it's
just a fight for squares it's about
maneuvering and um I've got to say it
feels like traditionally this would
favor Magnus Carlson he's so good
strategically so good that kind of
sensing where the important squares are
when to switch up uh the pace the
quickness of the game but uh Wesley he's
done done nothing wrong and evaluation
bar slightly preferring black I've got
to agree just uh we're kind of playing
by association with colors reversed yes
Wesley's have Tempo down on a known
opening but he's got everything covered
Tanya your dream Square on C5 that
Knight's going to be beautiful on this
Square feels like Magnus is taking some
big risks early on in this game and
evaluation But continuing to drop after
magnus's Retreat there white knight
wants to come around and stack on this
Pawn but he's not going to get time
surely Magnus uh Tanya are you agreeing
to my eyes it looks fantastic for black
yeah everything that you pointed out and
I also really like that Wesley captured
on B4 with that pawn on A5 at first it
looks like you're spoiling your Pawn
structure you're doubling up but you're
taking away some key squares from that
Knight on B1 well now the positions
change White had to spend some time
picking up that pawn and B4 and we see
the Queens are going to get traded off
because the A4 Pawn is really weak and
just coming back to Robert's Point
earlier about this being a reverse B
Gambit and extra Tempo that matters I
think Westy's approach to go with the
move B4 to B3 early on in the game to
not go for the the picking up of the
Pawn in these kind of positions perhaps
the extra Tempo doesn't matter as much
it doesn't and it's because it's a
relatively closed position so I'm with
you Tanya and Wesley just quickly played
Queen to A5 he released the tension I
think he's going into this game with the
Mantra I'm going to try to draw with the
black pieces and then press with white
because he could have kept his B4 Pawn I
actually think that keeping more pieces
on the board was favorable for black
because White's pieces were stepping on
each other's toes somewhat now after the
queen trade Mass Liquidation on the a
file the A4 Pawn is dropping I don't
think that black is any worse at the
moment that's for sure but I don't know
if there's so many winning chances left
because there aren't that many pieces
remaining o and some of these moves uh
in the game review here not approved of
by the computer this was a missed
opportunity for Wesley so to my eyes it
looks like a very natural move he's
trying to gain time now against this
white Rook actually if the Queens
disappear I wouldn't be surprised for
example on the next move if the black
king just shifts to D7 swings the other
Rook across and if the Queens are off
the board Black's pieces are so actively
placed wle so at least in my eyes
turning things in his favor I think
Magnus really needs to kind of pull the
break shift gears here and try to make
that draw Wesley on the camera smiling
as well uh he looks thrilled with his
position and rightly so I wish we could
see how Magnus is feeling that dark
shadow uh there we go brightening up
Suddenly but I don't think his mood is
feeling very bright with this position
here after the Queens leaving the board
now it's all about how active Black's
pieces are like Robert said earlier this
porn is doomed sooner or later Wesley
can of take it at his leisure and
nothing at all to worry about here for
black it's just about whether he can try
to turn it into an advantage even at
some
point and now the big question is David
has Wesley red grind like a grandm
because it looks like it might be time
to start thinking about that an end game
you got peace activity the A4 Pawn is
about to fall Black's King in the center
is actually ideally plays because you
don't even need to go shot Castle
anymore you could go with your king to
D7 as Wesley does it bring the other
Rook into play I'm loving Wesley's
position right now I love the way
Wesley's handling this because that pawn
A4 is not going anywhere it cannot
legally move and it cannot be defended
very easily so black wants to set up the
second Rook over to A8 to keep control
of this open file or Rook on B8 and then
slam it down on B2 so that's why Magnus
realizing he doesn't have all the time
in the world to just sit and see this
Rook get active he decides to strike in
the center with Pawn to F4 and if the
black pawn E5 is removed D4 is loose so
these are some difficult decisions for
Wesley he might just push his Pawn to F6
to keep a nice Pawn chain everything
defended but you see wesy investing some
time right now because there may be
tactics with that black king on D7 it's
still in the center of the board there's
still Rooks uh on the the position here
so I think Wesley he's just trying to be
accurate what Magnus shook his head he's
not happy black is certainly no
worse as you predict Robert there black
does play Pawn to F6 we see a quick
trade and Magnus activates his knight uh
this game looks like it's roughly in the
balance but perhaps Magnus here needing
to be slightly more careful than Wesley
uh just to M that uh kind of equal
position maybe it's time to jump over to
check out another game we'll update
everyone of course on these Ms I want to
check out the other game we've been
talking about a lot Maxim vasra against
Dennis lazeric and we jump in at a
moment where again a small cross a
missed opportunity for black natural to
me and level material in this one Robert
what are your first instincts about this
position how should we evaluate it well
I'm just we come in and there's
immediately a Miss Right giving an X and
normally you would say that the black's
position looks quite solid to my eyes
the bishop on B2 for white it's not
playing the Knight on H4 where is it
going so perhaps black has something a
little bit stronger but the position
looks very sturdy from Dennis lack's
perspective I think he's handled this
opening perfectly he has not worse in
the slightest and I don't know where
white even hopes to build an advantage
from Tanya um are you uh kind of
favoring either side here looks like
maybe denn Dennis has escaped the
opening in good shape here I think both
the games that we've checked out black
is doing great and this one danis in the
earlier one Wesley they've gotten out of
the opening without too much trouble
this one is so symmetrical the pawn
structure The Miner piece balance
everything no such weaknesses that last
move by Dennis C6 taking control of that
Central D5 Square making sure that white
doesn't have any jumps with that Knight
on D5 anymore so Maxim decides to
improve the position of that other
Knight that you were pointing out Knight
coming back to F3 but I'm still not
seeing how white actually makes progress
you can't really push the C Pawn because
the B4 Pawn will be hanging there so the
B2 Bishop still struggles to come into
the game I agree with both of you that
for Dennis this has been a good
start great start for Dennis lazic and
this one it does feel like the Calm
before the storm uh long long way to go
we look at the clock times with our new
time control this season uh both players
still with plenty of time left and uh
two second increment to boot Max
slightly ahead on the clock there but I
think we should go back to that Marquee
game uh to Magnus Carson against Wesley
so because that one feels like it's
racing towards a conclusion and uh yeah
we're deep into the end game
now he's got a set of Rooks off the
board but visually it looks so
attractive uh my eyes at least for black
Black's King more active in the center
than white it can choose which direction
to go later Black's Bishop keeping the
white king uh feeling a bit
uncomfortable for now and at the right
moment you still can take enough
umt do you think Magnus here has he kind
of survived the worst or can Wesley
continue to be ambitious he jumps in
with a knight wow and he forced that
Rook to a whoa what's he pre-moving
Knight to C1 I mean if the Rook went to
A2 Knight C1 would have picked up the E2
Pawn but wesy trying to get that one
anyway and look at this exclamation
point given to Bishop to G4 uh he's
trying to provoke this E Pawn to push
because a pawn chain is only as strong
as its base pawn and so the E2 D3 C4
Pawn chain look nice and steady
everything well defended but if you have
to push up to E3 then that pawn on E uh
D3 becomes a Target Bishop D1 becomes
available and then Knight on C2 is in
some trouble the A4 Pawn remains loose
so white pieces are awkwardly placed I
actually you know at first like what's
Wesley doing pre-moving but he's that
strong at even bullet chest that he
understands the position and the
Dynamics seem to be favoring
black oh look at this Magnus just
ignores the threat what's his idea this
Pawn is simply falling andley gobbles it
up he's trying to undermine the Black
Knight now but Wesley he's destroyed
that pawn chain you were talking about
Robert this is a peace sacrifice he's
given up his Knight and uh I'm assuming
it's going to be captured what else then
black will take A4 pawn and he's going
to bank on these two connected passes in
the center to just race down the board
is this genius is this Magnus Magnus I
was was it a bit of both uh Wesley
to try and win this
game I love it I love this approach by
Wesley Magnus said his strategy against
Wesley is about hustling him hustling
Wesley's lack of aggression we've seen
none of that Wesley's going all out he
delays the picking up of the a pawn he
first picks up the central pawns and now
he sacrificed an entire piece but we've
got to do a deep dive into this position
because for the moment Wesley's down a
night in the position you're pointing
out the E Pawn also the black Rook
jumping onto that second rank with a ton
of pinning ideas with retu coming up how
much trouble is this I see the evalar
says it's still even but from a
practical perspective is Magnus feeling
the heat right now I think he is I mean
this position looks uncomfortable for
white because the Knight on C2 is
already threatened by the bishop as you
mentioned Tanya Rook A2 becomes an
immediate threat and let's say you want
to jump your Knights forward somewhere
Knight F3 is met by the simple King to
D6 improving the location of the black
king because you're defending your loose
Pawn the king is active used as a weapon
in the end game so I'm looking at this
position and Magnus needs to be very
careful here because if he makes a
single mistake it's no longer a balanced
game it's completely in Wesley's
favor guys I want to make you guess the
best move I took a peak I thought
White's position is so ugly here so
unattractive how does Magnus hold this
together what do you think White's best
move is
here it's unfindable for a human that's
a big
clue uh
I'm gonna just I
think yeah I was gonna actually say
Knight A1 because the way you ask the
question is so leading and it's not a
natural move at all but if anyone on
this planet can find it I think it's
Magnus Carlson wow look at him shifting
in his chair there Magnus leaning
forward he knows this is a key position
uh I was attracted to your king E1 there
Tanya as well I think a very logical
move but in the end after a move like
Pawn to C5 whites Knights are just stuck
pretty much zuk Swang but Knight A1 is
the best move according to the computer
the idea is to Loop Round this Knight to
rotate it round to B3 and uh the knights
Superfluous knights we sometimes call
them but they cling on to each other for
example if the Black Brook drops down
Knight to B3 and for now you're holding
but this is so hard to evaluate I mean
to my eyes it looks like black plays
Roberts move King D6 the pawns are
rolling running but after King to F3 you
have a semi blockade on kind of some
important squares and the Knights
surviving but Magnus need needs to find
this move and I think it's almost
impossible Knight to A1 he plays Knight
F3 instead and now Roberts move King D6
looks like it gives black a big
Advantage black moving forward in
control question mark given to that move
we can't fault it very human Knight F3
especially in Raper chess who's going to
look at a move like KN A1 and Magnus
gives his piece back this is going to be
oneway traffic now level material yet
again but at the right moment you can
take this Pawn not yet because there
might be some Knight Forks some Knight
checks uh so maybe Wesley takes some
time out to guard against that but uh
yeah feels like Magnus in big big
trouble in game one today well Tanya I
was about to ask you that Magnus up a
piece for two pawns but those pawns were
running up the board restricting wh's
pieces do you think this is a good
practical try for Magnus because at
least what he could Envision for a draw
blockade on the dark squares trying to
take away some of these remaining black
pawns do you think the draw seems more
Within Reach now I think Knight A1 the
move that you were discussing and Robert
that you pointed out is so difficult to
play and to even find it's not even on
your radar a retreating move all the way
back to A1 you're not sure how you're
coming out of the fix that you're in so
you really want to try and simplify the
position I think you're on point Magnus
just wants to get out of this game he
wants to find the fastest way to
neutralize but this might not be
neutralizing at all because a bishop
versus knight in these end games is good
news for black you can try and push you
have to watch out for that Knight on G7
getting trapped Bishop to F7 it comes
back how are you retreating with the
Knight if the minor pieces get traded
off this is winning for black are you
going G4 King
F5 a knight F5 I'm sorry process of
elimination you have to play G4 this is
the only route back for the White Knight
but Wesley has cut off this Square F5
now taken away uh from the White Knight
and big threat the knight's still
trapped like you say Tanya if there's a
trade Knight for Bishop black will win
due to this distraction the outside pass
Pawn so Magnus now needs to keep his
Knight alive is it the move G5 just to
stop the threat but this is still
incredibly ugly you're playing without a
piece and Black's Pawn looks like it's
racing down the board he plays it again
process of elimination
but is he going to save this game
exclamation mark only move there from
Magnus he surviving by the skin of his
teeth Robert do you see any resources
can black continue pushing well what
white now wants to do is play H4 H5 and
G6 just get rid of that H7 Pawn because
if that pawn is no longer on the board
then the white pieces will go march on
over to the C Pawn either blockade it or
sacrifice the Knight for that last Pawn
a lone King and Bishop cannot deliver
Checkmate for those of you who are newer
in the audience so that is what white is
aiming for get all of Black's pawns off
the board even if you have to sacrifice
your knight in the process a great move
G5 H4 comes next the black king kind of
has to stay put because as it goes up to
F4 Knight can now slide back to E6 with
check and the Knight is safe yeah Magnus
should be saving this game now that the
White Knight escaped that dungeon on G7
let's take a zoom out of this one very
briefly uh just to check in on the other
action Magnus does play the best move
gets his Knight out of Dodge there and
this is the bird's eye view we see the
evaluation bars mostly roughly around
the center um Vash gra against lazic has
been level since we left it not much to
report there apart from maybe lazic KN
uh on the top left of your screens in
the top left corner as well the other
games NPI on the back foot against man
of the moment Jose Martinez Magnus
should draw now against wo and fed
against fuja also roughly balanced um
what catches your eye here Robert from
the other games I think that Jose
Martinez game with the black pieces
against two-time World Championship
Challenger Yan theom because Jose
celebrated his birthday a couple days
ago when he won came in first place in
the playin then he was able to sail
through the placement and now here he is
in division one so the recent birthday
boy look at that last move by the way
way G5 allowing a fork with check on F6
but you sometimes need to protect your
King by getting active on the side that
you're being attacked because now that
pawn on G5 is well defended by another
Pawn on H6 its best friend whereas the
pawn on G7 that was well within White's
attacking range and queen takes H6 with
on the docket so I love moves like this
and I love the way that Jose plays chess
even though he's down to 22 seconds
remaining this is super complex and uh
Jos bam his birthday week seems like
it's continuing and Yan naami doesn't go
to pick up that exchange on E8 because
at night on H5 it's such a key piece for
white Yan it's very important for him to
try to create the initiative he's down
an exchange currently but practically
still a lot of Chances with black king
being so weak and just 20 seconds to
defend this position it feels like it's
all about the clock uh I'm used to
seeing uh Jose here just hustle his
opponents whenever I play him on
chess.com he's always flagging me you
know he's so quick so so instinctive but
yeah npish she has to use this clock
situation against black now I'm not sure
whether you jump in with your knight and
kind of again hint that you might go for
this Rook which is almost trapped or do
you at some point push a pawn forward
try to break this uh kind of stronghold
on G5 with your pawns but the white Rook
as well lacking squares this is not easy
White's queen super passive this is why
White's attack is not that dangerous and
evaluation bar I think to be trusted in
this type of position um it's so wild
it's so chaotic uh sometimes we say
don't trust the bar it's a very human
position but feels like Jose has ridden
the storm and uh wow Pawn H4 I was
reluctant to suggest it immediately
maybe a bit later because suddenly this
Rook lacking squares and instead he
jumps in with the Black
Knight wow what a move yeah he's
defending by attacking he's just trying
to remove all of White's most aggressive
pieces if the knights come off the board
The Rook takes on D4 so look at whoa y
goes Knight takes G5 and jum jumps in
with his Knight because the D2 Bishop is
loose and the Queen on C1 is under
attack everything's hanging for white
which piece do you sa there three up for
grab's next move you've got to check but
the black king can simply run you could
take G5 I'm just looking at all the
checks David you're pointing out the
king running E7 is the only square is
Bishop G5 something that you can start
looking at already I think you have to
Tanya I think you're completely right
this Bishop's dropping anyway you might
as well sell it for a high price you can
get check and he goes for the check you
get your queen out of the way as well
but black is a rook up black has a whole
extra Rook yes uh the white Knights can
fork and win back some material but the
black king if it gets over to B8 this is
game over black is too much material two
more moves and Jose Martinez is going to
get this Victory 12 seconds what do you
think Robert is this going to be enough
I think it that jman has the clear Edge
that's what Jose is known as his
username and it's the petan King march
and look at that Rook takes Knight on
apparently wasn't the best move it's
impossible not to play that when someone
takes your piece you want to capture
back and I think the one thing keeping
white potenti in this game is that H4
Pawn it's not a shield for the white
king it's a passer that you want to push
wow wow he's so good double exclamation
mark that last move dropping a bomb on
the position Queen to G1 check will lead
to Checkmate it's that famous combo the
queen and Knight teaming up at this
point it's pretty much against the lone
King and oo the petosan King march you
mentioned Robert this time it's the
white king that's running up the board
both Kings have been doing a bit of
dancing here but the white king is
doomed no way to escape if you step
forwards F5 there's going to be a deadly
check on F3 and white has to lose even
more material Yan she smiles and he's
about to
resign this is it's almost and he does
it and J reacts he gets the dub he wins
the first game against yanomi the
birthday gifts keep coming
oh yes and wow what a game that was
Knight D4 checkmate with so many pieces
smothering the white king so what a
final touch from josam from Jose
Martinez and you saw how much it meant
him David he gave us that fist pump in
celebration and there's action happening
elsewhere there was a draw in the
meantime between Wesley so and Magnus
Carlson uh there's a deep end game
between lazic and VRA but this one's
still going and 4 seconds on the clock
for fua exclam Mark but he's wow he's
battling pawns both sides of Pawns
running down the board this black A2
Pawn close to touchdown and white pawns
soon running but uh Robert help me out
whose position is favorable here
evaluation Bar says level but this one
surely is anyone's game oh look at that
how quickly the tables turn but Bishop
E6 giving a check apparently not the
right followup so for both these players
it's good that they don't know the
evaluation as this position is anyone's
game it's extremely
messy oh it's messy but now the black
Rook is infiltrated this was so cunning
from fuja with only a few seconds left
this Bishop's trapped and black is on
the brink of making a new Queen uh black
luckily can give up his own Bishop to
stop White's f- Pawn if the white Pawn
ever pushes it's simply going to be
eliminated feels like black suddenly now
out of nowhere ahead in the race White's
King got active but in the end walks
into a dead end and uh here we go this
whole variation is playing out it's all
about the black a pawn and FIA shutting
the door White's Pawn dropping no more
counter
play Tanya what do you think is this
just going to be over now yeah I think
it's uh it's quite beautifully played
the last couple of moves by Ala fuja now
there's nothing to be done as you
pointed out the ewn isn't moving forward
anymore and it's going to be the awn
that will decide the game looks like OA
is about to take the first win and
meanwhile Wesley so Magnus Carlson did
end in a draw yeah and well that game
was a draw this one looks like it's
great for black but I can see oh he
drops the a away no time for fua he saw
Knight C2 coming and now it should be a
hold with best play but should have
would have Coulda this is now speed
chess and by the way rook and Bishop
versus Rook theoretically drawn
everybody but really hard to save when
you have no
time yeah with seven seconds on the
clock now white needs to give up the
Knight for this black pawn and try to
hope to defend that but this is going to
be a long fight ahead no certainty here
and fua he knows he was winning so might
be a bit of frustration in him uh White
can now give a check for example uh with
the white Rook but no okay the Pawn's
marching the White Knight is a bit
offside and the bar disappears this
check and White's pieces are just too
far away they're not going to stop this
black pawn from racing down the board
it's going to Sprint towards touchdown
on
C1 better say if he just rushed a bit
too much 25 seconds he didn't coordinate
his pieces and look how the bishop
totally dominates this Knight the bishop
on this diagonal just cutting across the
white Knights Retreats
and well see a result now he surely
isn't going to let this one slip ala
fer you've been talking about the
defensive technique of sacrificing that
Knight for the C3 Pawn that Knight isn't
going to get to the C3 Pawn no it's
because iiv understood the assignment he
knew what white was going for and he
said I'm not going to allow it and now
the king can just March forward help
that pawn escort it to the other side
and then Knight on D7 it needs to be
back in White's territory it's way too
far away Knight's being slow moving
pieces not
helping oh and he's going to use the
bishop as a blockader the black Bishop's
going to come in uh to help the pawn
promote on C1 or The Bishop's going to
help block some checks there we go
Bishop to F2 shuts the door in fed's
face and black makes a new Queen it's a
matter of time now it looks like they've
swapped sides blacks pieces are starting
on wh's starting row but a check double
attack game over fuja takes the win the
first game of the
day ala fuja can but but he was winning
earlier on he messed it up FV had his
chance but in the end manages to get
fev's night out of the game a brilliant
conversion there David that means we
have finished our round one games some
interesting results there uh Robert what
what surprised you the most about this
one well the players winning with the
black pieces that's not something that
we can say all the time although in tata
Steel in the classical chest it seemed
like in the opening rounds that was the
norm but for Jose Martinez and their
alaa huge wins with the black pieces
yeah and there we have our game one from
the winners quarterfinals it is a best
of four two and a half points takes the
match and it is Jose Martinez and alira
fuja who take the lead in their match
the other two matches start with a draw
Dennis lazovic with a confident hold
against Maxim Vash lra Wesley so in
driver's seat with the black pieces and
another confident hold against uh Magnus
Carlson who was on the defense but got
the job
done what a first round to start the day
Magnus living life on the edge surviving
by the skin of his teeth and those two
black WIS definitely the highlights fuja
it was in the balance for so long but he
turned on the magic when it was
necessary deep in the end game but
Martinez I've got to say Robert just
looks like the man in form right now in
this rapid form out and 10 minutes on
the clock for him it's plenty he's just
crushing the best players in the world
well for Jose he doesn't get to play
that much over theboard chess but he
thrives online he plays in every single
title Tuesday he's a streamer a content
creator and somebody who lives for the
moment and he lives for that time
pressure because he's always it with
minimal time on his clock those few
seconds that's when he actually brings
out his best I mean the way he just
checkmated yeah NE amnish she's King in
those final few moves getting the queen
on the back R Queen G1 Queen H1 just
absolute precision and that checkmate
with the Knight on that Central Square
that's going to be a tough one for Yanna
pesi to get out of but he needs to do
that Yan starts with the black pieces in
the next one but also equally impressive
Dennis lavic against Maxim
VRA he didn't get to cover that game too
much it was just very level throughout
Dennis he's so good at keeping control
and uh just justifies his billing as the
underdog gets that draw great result for
young Dennis in the the meantime looks
like we're jumping straight back into
the action we're awaiting Wesley so's
return to his laptop screen to that
chair that setup whatever we're going to
call it Wesley getting ready to fight
I've got to say guys I love what he did
in game one he just needs to do it all
over again in game two uh just with
Magnus and I was just about to say are
we gonna see a one B3 an opening that
Wesley so played in The Grand Final in
the season tour Final in 2023 against
Magnus gson but we are not seeing any of
that he starts with the queen Pawn
opening and wow Magnus going are we
going to see a king's Indian by Magnus
in this one oh it depends yeah yeah I
was going to say depends what kind of
mood he was in but David you saw it
before I could even respond do you see
Wesley by the way he's like bringing up
his blanket making sure that it's
sitting nicely on his lap as we are
going to venture into one of the most
aggressive openings from the black side
if Wesley allows to happen because you
could take this into quieter Waters if
he's
chooses uh the king's Indian defense
Magnus only really plays it when he's
all out for blood for victory um I very
rarely see Magnus employ this defense
when he's happy to just kind of keep
things solid when he just wants to kind
of grind it out in Long end game this
one uh only in the biggest of occasions
in mus win situations with black usually
so it's a big sign uh from Magnus to
Wesley saying yes you got you got close
in round one but now I'm going to fight
fire with fire and I'm going to come
back at you and Robert you mentioned
taking the game into quieter Waters I
don't want to see Wesley for example
trade off Pawns in the center here I
don't want to see him trade off and get
the Queens off the board which he has
done in the past on occasion no he
castles keeping all the tension and uh
yeah this one's shaping up nicely
Mainline Kings Indian all these romantic
openings these attacking openings
they're coming back into fashion which
we love to see so many kings gambits in
T Steel and now in the Champions chest
the uh Kings Indian instead and Magnus
just choosing the weight he's going to
set up Knight to D7 Knight to C6 taking
on D4 Magnus is played on occasion H6 is
the trendy move here uh all the cool
kids are playing I don't understand it
but plenty of choice Magnus the first
Applause and for Magnus Carlson as you
said he doesn't really play this that
often and you look to the left of the
board that shows the statistics when
this opening is played in Master Level
games so Wesley so you know he knows
that this opening should be good for
white in fact the engines they love it
because they they like the extra space
that white gets especially if he push
this Pawn from D4 up to D5 but by
releasing the tension if white in fact
does push this Pawn black will move the
Knight away from F6 and play F5 himself
opening up the king side so Wesley he
knows that the computer is a fan of this
from the white side he has experience
but he also has experience playing
Hikaru Nakamura who crushed him in one
game because this opening can be vicious
from the black side depending on how
white tries to adopt the
setup
and white needs to now decide it is that
moment because with magnus's last move
eyeing that Knight on F3 there's more
pressure on that Central D4 Pawn so
finally Wesley has to take a call he
either captures on E5 or blocks the
center with the move D5 uh David is
there a third option to try to keep the
tension going
here perhaps the third option would be
to use the bishop and guard this square
but uh I favor your choices there Tanya
depending on Wesley's mood uh I think
the most ambitious if Wesley's up for a
fight okay he actually plays the third
choice there Bishop to E3 I was going to
say he could push his Pawn forward a the
computer is such a harsh critic giving
that move a question mark but he could
also have taken the pawn off on E5 and
there would have been a bunch of
exchanges uh so Bishop to E3 Let's
ignore that question mark for now I
think this time will give Wesley the
benefit of the doubt but uh this is
perhaps not approved of by computers
because after a trade of F3 Magnus I
think that would be the consistent full
up he goes for it now after a trade he's
going to bring his Knight out and this
bishop uh a bit similar to Robert
pointing out in the previous game Magnus
as Bishop on the long diagonal this is
going to be the MVP most valuable piece
and Magnus yeah I think he's he's going
to be happy Dart Square bind White's
Bishop on F3 is just blocked in staring
at its own pawns so I like what Magnus
has done Wesley not the most ambitious
way of fighting against the Kings Indian
but this is ambitious from the black
side there's a famous game maybe the
stem game of this variation voic versus
Fabiano Carana where Fabiano played
Bishop on G7 takes Knight on C3 that
seems Unthinkable to our chess Learners
out there you're giving away the bishop
that helps protect the dark squares in
front of your king whenever you're fing
ketto you typically want your Bishop to
sit there because it stares across the
diagonal and protect squares like H6 and
F6 down the line so your opponent cannot
invade but Bishop takes C3 has a clear
point that with Rook E8 the Black Knight
stepping forward to E5 and C5 that
White's pawns they do well to take care
of critical squares but they're also
extended quite far and thus vulnerable
so these are big decisions for both
players and I think that they have that
stem game the voic Carana game in their
mind and I think this last move by
Wesley goes against that plan that you
were pointing out because if black was
to capture on C3 now you can take with
the queen you don't really compromise on
the pawn structure and you get all the
advantages of the bishop pair meanwhile
David I think white is also threatening
to move Bishop to 86 to my understanding
black shouldn't trade the pair of
Bishops in these position how can Magnus
avoid these further trades here I love
it Tanya thinking about what the
opponent wants the opponent might want
to just get rid of this sniper on G7 uh
this Archer from afar so by playing a
move such as Rook to E8 here um I'll
just put this on the board Rook to E8
now suddenly black would be free to
decide what to do with this bishop yes
you can still trade them off but you
also have the added option of Simply
dropping back keeping the bishop on the
long diagonal and saying to White
actually your Bishop looks pretty but
it's not doing anything on H6 and uh if
we go back to the game wow he's just
taking it off immediately Robert the
propit just take that piece they tell
you to study your Classics I know that a
game from a few years ago isn't
considered a classic because not enough
time has gone by but Fabiano Carana
teaches not just us but Magnus Carl in a
very important and instructive lesson
that sometimes it is okay to say you
know to heck with the rules the
principles that I learned sometimes we
could throw them out the window if the
position calls forward and look at this
queen of6 queen trade being offered we
talk about the bishop pair Advantage
here it's the knights that are going to
do some damage because they can stare
and hop over pieces a knight on E5 you
know hit a bishop on F3 a Pawn on C4 a
knight on F6 or C5 hits that pawn on e4
and if to protect that pawn on e4 you
have to move your dark Square Bishop but
as soon as that Bishop leaves E3 a
knight can jump into D4 as well so many
critical squares are Black's Knights for
the taking I think Wesley has to be very
careful here it's not like the engine
hates his position but it does seem
easier to play from the black side
because the bishop on F3 in particular
it does not have a useful diagonal it's
staring into its own E4 pawn and if it
tries to move to a new diagonal it
stares into his own C4 Pawn no active
real estate for that
Bishop really instructive I'm going to
go uh check out that game forter against
kowana just to remind myself and clearly
Magnus has been studying fabby's games
there really kind of catching Wesley off
guard we see the clock situation Magnus
kind of a minute and a half up on the
clock could be important for later but
yeah just Breaking All the Rules but you
got to know the rules what in order to
figure out when to break them and yeah
these Knights I'm always biased towards
Bishops but on this occasion I'll give
Magnus the benefit of the doubt they're
jumping the knights coming in uh yeah
looks like Wesley the one with questions
to answer I think this is the perfect
moment to zoom out uh maybe we go to the
bird's eyee view as Magnus applies
pressure to Wesley's position and okay
hey lots of different types of games
some more exciting than others I've got
to say uh where are your eyes drawn
Tanya it's the one on the extreme right
of our screen you got Ali RZA fuja
against fedos and the position is all
kinds of Bonkers White's got a queen out
on H4 the kings are in the center
there's a knight on B5 Black's spawn
already on D4 that's the position that
has gotten my attention um while
meanwhile we see the Central boards it's
pretty level between Wesley and Magnus
still let's do a deep dive into this one
yeah and normally we won't do this this
is fast Furious rapid chest but I'm
going to do a quick rewind to the start
of this game uh because it is crazy as
you mentioned Tanya so unorthodox so
irrational this position white is just
one a pawn but black wow okay we'll do a
very quick dive it started Life as a
kocan and uh in in advanced variation it
was Pawn to C5 just blowing open the
center and after a capture White's Queen
takes on D4 and yeah let's catch up the
White Queen dancing it gets harassed so
often remember kids remember folks don't
bring your queen out too early she is
the most valuable piece any time she
gets hit she has to move and let's show
this tactic on the board super cool
Knight takes Pawn now ignoring the
Knight taking this one instead if the
Knight had been captured then Queen to
A5 is a well-known Fork a double attack
black regains the piece with uh interest
so uh Bishop to E2 the reply from fuja
and this is the game position uh and
okay a
check feels like it's calming down
slightly but uh still nice to see the
players kind of throwing out these crazy
creative moves early on well it seems
like the come before a potential second
storm because black has not developed
the kingside pieces you see the Knight
on G8 The Rook on h8 they're sitting at
home and this A2 Pawn is loose do not
get greedy prioritize your development
and to make sure your king is safe
because if you first swap Knights you
know so the Black Knight isn't hanging
on E5 and then you decide to take this
Pawn on A2 white is just going to Castle
the King give you that second Pawn on B2
and then go right after your king with
moves like Rook to E1 Rook to B1 the
engine actually says that this is okay
for black that is shocking to my eyes
because it does feel like with the black
king still in the center not casting
anytime soon you should just be hopeless
I think practically speaking there's no
way you survive but an engine it's the
best chess player on the planet for a
reason it's heartless it's cold blooded
and it's says I can defend this even
though I have activated absolutely
nothing besides my
queen going to say he's never ever going
to do this he's never going to try this
and of course he doesn't Knight to F6
he's too well trained classically
trained there fed he gets his pieces out
and really destructive there Robert I
totally agree I don't think any grandmas
would seriously consider getting that
trigger happy that porn hungry and uh
start grabbing on A2 now it's just time
for black to get castled do the same as
white and level material
um which side do you favor here Tanya uh
whose side do you think is easier to
play just really slightly I like white
hair and I think that's because of the
piece activity and the placement of the
pieces without the dark Square Bishop on
G7 I think the black king will be
slightly vulnerable on the king side as
well also notice how white can line up
The Rook on E1 and start targeting that
E7 Pawn eventually once the knights on
the center of the board are traded off
the bishop whether it lands eventually
on F3 which I think it might now with
this Knight trade you could recapture
with Bishop takes Knight bring that Rook
to E1 just feel that White's pieces are
are more active and like you said David
easier to play and in this time format
that is the most critical
thing having won the first game of today
uh he can use that kind of uh to good
effect I feel like this type of position
he's pretty much provoking fed maybe on
the next move to go grabbing this Pawn I
said he would never do it on the last
move but at least now he's one move only
away from lling it feels slightly kind
of less risky to go for that PA now but
fua yeah with that win up his sleeve
already draws not the worst result and
okay he takes with a knight instead uh
bit of a surprise the Knight looks
really beautiful in the center the white
Bishop now not happy about that decision
um but ultimately feels like black
should just get castled don't risk
taking this Pawn I don't even see a
specific concrete reason not to but it
feels all wrong and fed whoa he goes for
it
no way I am shocked that fedos have made
this decision but perhaps it's
influenced by the first game of the
match remember he did lose game one with
the white pieces when Fu was able to
Queen at the end so he's thinking it
might be now or never let's mix it up
but Bishop C4 I think this is why Ali R
took with the Knight rather than with
the bishop yes a bishop on F3 looked
great but here a bishop on C4 hits the
queen on A2 and the pawn on F7 and if
you continue to be Pawn hungry and you
grab this Pawn on B2 I think you can
move your Rook to E1 but the C1 Rook
it's counterintuitive but if you move
the E F1 Rook Instead The Rook on C1 was
loose in many of the resulting positions
but if you slide the uh C1 Rook away as
you show Castle Rook takes E7 is no
longer possible but with a rook on F1
safely tucked away you can successfully
grab this Pawn in the seventh rank so
just try to Envision that in these
positions there could have been a rook
on C1 which would have made this line
impossible now instead of leaving The
Rook on C1 That's The Rook that steals
the pawn on the seventh rank yeah I just
want to go one move further one move
deeper black can Ste a third Pawn he's
said a b he might as well say C and take
the C Pawn but white will at the very
minimum start doubling up stacking up
the Rooks and it feels like there's
going to be all sorts of trouble Black's
Queen remember has to guard this Knight
otherwise Queen takes Knight using the E
file pin but already all sorts of taxit
in the air um I'm looking at the White
Knight leaping forward to hit the F7
Pawn maybe even sacrifices on this
Square in the near future Black's King
will not survive this storm
so if we go back to the game position I
think F he's just got to go for it
provoke this second Pawn capture Bishop
C4 initiative blade momentum at every
move with a threat and white builds up
this phenomenal phenomenal attack he
doesn't see the evaluation bar of course
he doesn't even play Bishop C4 but uh
now at least fed can get castled he's
trying to transpose into that variation
Robert but you mentioned it the wrong
Rook White's C Rook needed to be on this
Square hence maybe this uh Red Cross
that we see attached to this last move a
Miss from Ala
fua and it's difficult to yeah it's
difficult to move a rook that's already
seemingly developed although a rook on
C1 isn't exactly active uh but it's
because that Rook is loose there in many
of these continuations Bishop C4 Queen
takes B2 now it becomes apparent what I
was trying to indicate earlier that the
C1 Rook is undefended loose pieces drop
off it does not allow The Rook on E1 to
freely take a pawn in its path so alza
he is playing this inaccurately fedos of
he's up on the clock he's also up upon
Pawn so if things don't clarify soon I
believe that fedos can play for the
upper hand his position it doesn't look
that scary anymore and I love this move
that F just play Queen to B4 defending
his loose Pawn attacking Black's Pawn to
E7 and threatening to trap the queen on
A2 C4 big big threat now on the board
the black queen is defenseless no
squares to run to so you have to really
careful now um I guess first instinct
would be to flee lift up your skirt run
back to safety if you're the black queen
but maybe something more ambitious as
well for fed he's a very ambitious
player he didn't grab that pawn on A2
just to run away with his Queen uh so
big big moments ahead in this game uh
but evaluation Bar says roughly level
and I think for now we have to trust it
uh let's zoom out to the birds I view
let's see if the other games have caught
up in terms of excitement right now and
okay we see on the left of your screens
Dennis lazic against Maxim vasra it's a
rook end game level pawns level pieces
feels like it's fizzling out towards a
draw Martinez against npom Nishi also
level in a rook and night end
game I favor nish's chances but roughly
level for now and uh W Le so against
Magnus Carlson U Robert Tanya what do
you think should we stick with our
current game or go to one of those uh
simplified
positions I think we have we have to
head over to magnus's game he's up a
pawn currently pieces look active but
Wesley trying to get both his Rooks on
the seventh rank so let's get a quick
check in with Wesley under two minutes
on the clock this time on the defense
and that's super scary when you're
playing against Magnus Carlson an end
game that he's pushing it is so hard to
keep things under control but it looks
like white has compensation here right
you've got this dark Square Bishop that
can line up on the long diagonal The
Rook from B2 is jumping on to B7 to try
to creat some threats yes I see black is
upon Pawn up but to me practically it
looks like Wesley's got his chances what
do you think Robert I love magnus's
position and if we do have a couple
seconds I actually want to point out
that Magnus made four great moves in a
row he earned those exclamation points
because Wesley sacrificed the pawn
thinking that he would probably get it
back quickly and the answer is no he's
not and he does have activity but if you
just go back right before Knight takes
before before Wesley you know he gave up
a Pawn there and that four moves in a
row were ex exclamatory from the black
side you stole the pawn The Rook slid to
B3 and then Magnus was able to keep his
extra Pawn this looked like the obvious
try from white but look at how Magnus
danced with his Knights first hitting
the Rook on B3 The Rook slides back then
planting a knight on C2 to save the
Knight that's under attack hitting the
rook in the corner The Rook slides to
hit the Knight that is now hit twice by
two Rooks and he takes a bishop on F3
Returns His Knight to D4 he does steal a
pawn in this position so was great and
knights jumping jumping to steal a
Destiny's Child song and it landed
Magnus an extra pawn and now we have the
game position which does look like it's
fizzling out I think Wesley had just
enough compensation Tanya you seem to be
right yeah I think so because go on
David I was just going to say you take
it away Tanya but when I first saw this
position on the B ey view I didn't count
the points correctly I thought okay
Wesley's doing really well but that
beautiful uh kind of sequence of n jumps
giving black the advantage Tanya how how
easy uh is it for Wesley to go this game
towards safely do you
feel it's not going to be easy he's
playing against Magnus he's down upon
pawn and that's never going to be easy
but again I'm just going to reiterate
the fact that this bishop on the long
diagonal is not only doing a great job
on this one but is not going to Target
that other Pawn on A5 and to me it looks
like Magnus has to try to get activity
he needs to jump in with that Rook is he
going to try to somehow find any meeting
net ideas against the white king Rook B3
comes to my mind trying to get play on
the king side I don't think you can go
passive trying to defend that A5 Pawn
what would be your approach with black
if you're pushing for a win here it's
difficult to choose sorry David I was
just going to say it feels like you know
as black you want to activate your king
but you don't have anywhere to go so
David you're the endgame Maestro you
have some loose pawns on A5 and maybe G5
how would you actually approach this
position uh normally I love my end games
when you have some level of stability
and uh you can kind of slowly improve
your pieces unfortunately it's one of
the those it's pure calculation I just
wanted to point out Tanya's move Rook B3
it's the most tempting and it would be
super strong if it wasn't for the fact
that white could immediately force a
draw with a check another check and
Black's King actually cannot Escape uh
from these barage of checks so really
frustrating for Magnus you can see that
on the camera uh and if we go back to
the game position after Bishop C3 he's
Frozen he hasn't moved what can he do uh
I don't see it I've got to admit um it's
really hard to come up with an idea
Knight to H4 instead he tries going
after that pawn on F3 that straggler but
uh okay at least he's trying to initiate
a race from Magnus Carlson and he's
given the black king an extra Escape
Square I think this might be really
sneaky if the black king sneaks out via
H7 G6 F5 a bit later on but Wesley Wow
exclamation mark for that move he
correctly assesses that he can just
trade everything off and uh now after
The Rook comes back and takes this Pawn
G5 is loose A5 is loose uh first he just
defends two pawns down wly so but he's
got everything under control um going to
say it now I think he's earned the draw
he's done it the hard way but he's
earned his half
point I'm loving the way Wesley is
handling these complicated position and
you could see the frustration on Magnus
right there I think he missed this idea
of Wesley not snapping up that C5 Pawn
immediately allowing Black's Rook to
jump into the attack with that B3 square
and picking up that F3 Pawn but he just
simply s side steps with the King it's
what we saw in round one as well Wesley
with the black pieces sacrificed the
pieace went for the most combative opt
uh option and Magnus was on the back
foot and it looks like Magnus did
everything created everything in this
game got the maximum and yet it's not
enough Wesley's defense has been on the
active side today it's more of the
offense kind of a defense I'm loving it
this end game here it's even material at
long last but I think that white may
have some good chances because the a
pawn Knights are slow moving pieces you
have to watch out for a passer on the
flank but the F3 Pawn a light Square
hard to defend with a dark Square Bishop
so both sides have their pluses here and
Wesley he's taking the safest approach
bringing his Bishop back keeping that
Knight honest to the G5 pawn and we may
see a repetition so I do think this one
is fully equal but if we don't mind if
we can go to the bird's eye view one of
the other games that is still going that
one looks like it's anyone's race and it
is a pawn race between Jose Martinez
second from the left here and yand
pishi wow look at that porn race also we
should mention fuja according to the B
at least has a winning Advantage a big
big attack but let's jump into that game
Martinez against Nom Nishi um we're
seeing some checks we're seeing some
moves here it's all about the quality of
porns not about the quantity black being
a porn up in that game and uh okay also
about the clock quality here with Jose
Martinez down to 20 seconds again he's
really living life on the edge on uh
kind of both Bard and clock I wanted to
say Black's got a great Advantage the
pawn running down but white does have
just enough counterplay not just is this
Pawn hanging but the Knight would then
be hanging behind it and uh some
calculation to be done
Nishi help me out uh T do you see any
good way for black to uh defend this
Pawn while keeping his dreams alive of
pushing for Glory you really want to
push that a pawn but the D5 Pawn was
hanging so he defended he saves me from
your question David such a difficult one
to answer how do you go ahead in this
position it's all about the race now the
knight from E3 can also perhaps go back
to F5 fighting against the G Pawn as
well black a pawn up but with just uh
with three minutes on the clock for nepo
and just 18 seconds for uh Jos Pim he
has to keep the tension on the board he
has to try to get that g Pawn moving I
think this is trouble and I see the eval
bar is equal but I think Yan pishi could
score his comeback win in this one
Robert I'm totally with you because look
at Jam he's slowing down trying to
figure out he does put his King on the
the last file if you take that pawn A4
there could be some checkmating Nets
against it and well Rook G4 defends the
A4 Pawn by hitting the Knight and whoa
that's a huge decision what happens if
black takes that pawn I think A4 is
Untouchable if you take this Pawn now
you walk into a pin on the fourth rank
so he wisely throws in a check first
he's asking the black king where it's
going and wow this is incredible play
incredible defense by Jam here because
now if the black king steps forward
where it wants to go the White Knight
drops back with a check this Pawn will
drop then the a pawn will drop and
Black's pawns collapse like Domino's so
he has to go back if he wants to keep
this game alive but suddenly the White
Knight jumps forward and goes to grab
the C Pawn all of the night Forks all of
the night jumps smile on the face of
npom Nishi frustrated I think by this
just Rock Solid defense from his
opponent on the back foot here again J
them how is he doing this living life on
the edge but always seems to have a
trick up his sleeve and it's on the
clock he's got less than 10 seconds he
still manages to do it but there's so
much drama on the the boards we're going
to quickly P up P pull up our bird's eye
view we've got a result coming in as
Dennis lazovic holds Maxim V grab for
the second game in a row meanwhile
massive massive drama on the Wesley
board as Wesley gets flagged Robert what
happened I'm very surprised but it looks
like on that board that magnus's pieces
were infiltrating and the white King was
in some danger we will get more
information if it was a connection issue
or Wesley just wasn't keeping an eye on
the clock but I'm keeping an eye on the
board on the absolute right hand side of
our screen fedos he was under attack but
as I look at the position as it
currently stands he has two minor pieces
for a rook so fedos have lost game one
he's suddenly willing himself to victory
in game two it would appear as he's got
a runaway passer on the a file and two
minor pieces a knight and Bishop for a
rook that's extra
material oh and fuia made that move with
three of a second left so frustrated
here there's nothing that can be done I
was going to say Black's Pawn is just
now going to push and first he defends
it two pieces will beat a rook
especially in conjunction with this
black a pawn white simply cannot fight
here without this Pawn even then might
black might be better but fua he had a
winning attack he let it slip took his
finger off the button for one second and
Strike Back comeback from F fed in this
match actually the Black Knight now can
just come into C2 in the next few moves
and push this Pawn for Glory there's no
way it's going to be stopped first he
activates his King closing this one out
we're going to see another uh equal
match here another tight match after
this miraculous comeback I've got to say
from fed proving that greed was good he
played provocative chess But ultimately
should be
rewarded well he didn't just want to
make a draw and have to rely on future
games and I just want to note that fedos
he kind of is a miracle worker how he
beat vid guti in the penultimate round
of the world rapid championship and
fedos of ended up as the silver medalist
so he has had bad positions before and
still won them here in this position
it's hopeless for white that a pawn two
minor pieces for The Rook it's easy for
Vladimir at this point fuja looking
frustrated on the camera and Yanna pomi
has got to be feeling the frustration as
well as his game ends in a draw just bam
holds a difficult difficult end game
with just seconds on the clock down upon
he does it again which means that Yan is
also still playing catchup meanwhile
fedos can he get the job done can he
level it and he does it as Ali throlls
in the dble he resigns FV is back in the
match oh what a boss move there he wins
the match gives up his Knight to promote
his pawn and then just stands up he
knows that he uh survived through a
really difficult game there and gets an
all important win forja again that Trend
continues he seems to win lose win lose
same from his Tata steel tournament so a
bit of frustration but still in a good
spot in the match uh I think we will
recount C that Magnus Carlson game as
well in a moment but uh these are the
results so far in the quarterfinals of
division one we're two games it's
halfway through the winnner
quarterfinals and Dennis lavic Maxim VRA
remains a level match meanwhile Ali Resa
fuja Vladimir FV also leveled but a
completely different storyline with two
decisive games FV striking back levels
the match Jose Martinez he continues his
birthday week f as he's still in the
lead against Yan pomi Magnus Carlson
does a surprising turnar around we
thought that everything was under
control for Wesley so he managed to
survive the worst but then Magnus
suddenly taking the win Robert how much
of a surprise is that for you cuz I'm
shocked right now it was shocking indeed
because Wesley so he is great at all
time controls including bullet chest but
sometimes when pressure keeps mounting
it's hard to show resistance forever so
I want to give credit to Magnus Carlson
for finding his chances I also want to
give another shout out to Vladimir fedos
winning on demand against alera fuja
sure fuia doesn't always show stability
but beating that guy oh that's difficult
so congrats to fosa but the job is not
done we still have two games to go in
these
matches yes and it is the action the
drama continues in the chessable Masters
and of course we will be back with more
as there are two more rapid games
remaining but just to get a Breo we're
going to take
a quick stroll through Paris with the
French defense Maestro Anish Kiri take a
[Music]
look
sh
welcome to a world where each game
writes a new story with endless
possibilities and surprising twists we
present the next big new tournament the
fre style chess goat challenge at the
Forefront of this epic chess spectacle
is none other than Magnus Carlson the
former world champion facing his first
duel with the reigning world champion
ding Len since his title victory
in addition to this top duel Carlson has
selected six other top Challengers to
make the tournament especially exciting
be sure to watch all the games on the
live stream at chess.com and on our
freestyle.lil and fascination of Chess
in a completely new light
[Music]
when I saw her for the first time it was
love at first
side I love how rich and complex she is
how sharp and principal her first
[Music]
steps how graceful her
movement Paris is a city of
[Music]
love I've come to find my
love for the French
[Music]
defense
Bo
[Music]
oh
n
[Music]
welcome back to chessable Masters
everyone we still got two big rapid
games coming up and talking about games
Robert if you were just about to play
against David Howell what would be the
one spell that you would cast on him
right before the game you know it's a
good question cuz to steal a line from
Nina Simone I'll put a spell on you and
I think unlike the natural disasters in
the world natural disaster on my chest
board so I'm going to use tornado
against you David I hope that messes you
up ah Robert I'm going to throw back a
freeze spell on you and hope that
that gives me a bit of luck in the
game well Robert's Frozen I'm sure some
of the players in the chessable master
would also like to cast un phrase Robert
would also like to cast a spell on their
opponents as they're playing catchup as
we go into round three but you can play
some spell chess on Annie chess use the
command Annie chess in chat or go to
Annie chess.com for all the spell chess
action and a spell fun on your opponents
we're about to have some fun in the
chessable Masters as we ENT round three
let's take a look at our score lines
just before the action starts
and there we are Wesley so needs to win
a game to level the match ala fuja
Vladimir FV two decisive games it's
level in their matchup meanwhile Yan Nei
is struggling against Jose Martinez and
I know Robert you're a Jos spam fan
you've spoken so much about his style
his speed in online chess what is it
that makes him so strong he he plays
practically he is able to be a bullet
Beast he plays in all the bullet braws
and chest
he's been in the bullet Chess
Championship so is his Play Perfect
absolutely not does he sometimes
struggle in the openings yes but he
knows when to make these quick decisions
and how to use his clock wisely and you
can't punish him when he is down under
20 seconds like you can other players so
Jose he's very solid he is hard to you
know take down in a tactical Skirmish
he's just a very allaround player and
one that uses his time when he's down to
his final seconds quite
wisely and josam has played over a
100,000 games on chess.com David and I
know you're someone who's always playing
bullet Blitz right before commentary
starts I've got to ask you before we get
into the chess action how many games
have you played on chess.com well I
don't think I can match this man's uh
efforts on chess.com uh I know I'm in
the tens of thousands but 100,00 games I
mean it's no coincidence that the top
players become good at chess it's uh
like any sport it's like playing an
instrument you have to practice practice
practice and J Bam's taken that to the
extreme but it's paying off now and uh
as Robert said a practical player he
never seems to get flustered no matter
how badly the opening goes even a middle
game slip up he always comes back strong
and now it's up to Nishi to come back
strong a point down still with only two
games to go he'll have to start taking
risks and that's where Jos B becomes
even more dangerous um this is not going
the way of the favorite on paper and uh
yeah I can't wait to see what he tries
next y pishi I also can't wait to see
how Wesley so reacts recover from that
heartbreaking defeat on the brink of a
draw against Magnus in that previous
game we kind of wrote it off but nope
something went a bit wrong on the board
on the clock and Wesley he needs to
strike back needs to come back
stronger yeah and Wesley so losing with
the white pieces in game two that's got
to hurt he starts with black he needs to
make sure to keep things under control
if Magnus wins with white in this one
that would be match over over for Wesley
so Wesley has to keep things on check
Magnus starts with the Kings Pawn
opening are we expecting a sicilian
Robert well when Wesley's in must-win
territory he often chooses to Sicilian
but why does he have to win this game if
he draws with black he does get a final
game with the white pieces and let's not
forget it's not like he was lost on the
board in that second game he lost on the
clock so for Wesley I think this is the
smart thing to do if Magnus wants to
force the draw in some Berlin let him do
that and use the white pieces in game
four h
big indicator wesle so's opening Choice
the Berlin defense that he would have
been happy with solidity and uh just a
draw with black straight off the bat
Magnus with his opening Choice playing
Pawn to D3 just slow pawn moves here
defending the center not allowing any uh
quick transitions here not allowing
pieces to fly off the board Magnus
hinting that he wants a full-blooded
fight as well so great to see from both
sides I'm loving the fact that Magnus
has kept the tension and Wesley's last
move just shuffling his Rook towards the
center not the main move but uh yeah
just keeping the tension alive Magnus is
probably the world's leading expert in
these slower types of Spanish opening
this is one of those branches uh so I'm
just uh Curious now to see how he
approaches this next phase of the game
all pieces on the board and likely to
stay that way for a long long time now
and uh you guys uh I'm going to ask you
first Tanya are you as optimistic after
seeing this opening Choice as I am of a
uh real battle in this clash in this
third game
you know when Wesley wants a draw it's
hard to imagine us getting a game but
that said Magnus goes for a line that
does keep the tension on the board keeps
the pieces on the board I think it's
going to be a slow one but Magnus will
play this out I don't believe we're
going to see too many trades early on
it's still a closed position it's going
to be a slow strategic fight I'm going
to go one step ahead and predict the
result in this I think we're going to
get a game four in this match David I
think regardless of how Magnus chooses
to go on in the middle game it will end
in a draw but Robert you seem to not
agree with me in this one no I just like
your prediction I think that you Wesley
he is showing that he's willing to fight
for the center by striking with D5 we
are just going to see him recapture but
the fact that he hasn't automatically
played yet it indicates to me that he's
not so certain about what to do here and
that should favor Magnus so this isn't
some deep theoretical position at least
not from the black side you could tell
by Wesley he has yet to move uh but
unlike some of the other games that
we're seeing it feels like they're just
playing a neutral position to see who
plays the better
chess and I was about to say Wesley he
paused for a reason and uh Robert uh you
were talking about maybe capturing it
back in the center there were a bunch of
choices you could take with the Knight
with the queen he actually
counterattacks against the white bishop
and this is a rare move but it's a known
move leevon aronian one of the leading
experts again in the Spanish opening uh
he has employed it on occasion hitting
this bishop and it's actually a pawn
sacrifice Magnus takes the Knight and he
could even have taken this Pawn on C6
but then his Pawn would have dropped in
the center so now allowing Wesley to
regain the material expecting the move
takes D5 here and yes black has
shattered pawns a shattered structure
but black is supremely active and for
example after a trade of pieces on the
C5 Square opposite color Bishops into
the mix as well so maybe at least
symbolically white has a small Edge
Magnus removing as much risk as possible
but Wesley playing ambitious chess uh
nice to see and uh clearly both players
they might spent a bit of time but still
uh in their opening preparation I
feel yeah and if Magnus doesn't capture
that Bishop on C5 it would give Wesley
the option to actually fall back with
the bishop to B6 on the next move and
keep the bishop at Advantage with the
dile open the D3 Pawn week I think that
would give Wesley something to play on
for I'm expecting Magnus to snap up the
bishop and go for the opposite color
Bishop position that you're talking
about but with the asymmetrical Pawn
structure I think we've got a game in
our hands this is a very non-standard
Berlin no this is not standard at all
yeah sorry David I was just going to say
that those bad pawns for black those
could be long-term weaknesses but the
opposite colored Bishops that we're
likely to see that should compensate but
not fully equalized Magnus has been
known to win positions with even less of
an advantage than this he's been known
to win all sorts of positions actually
both of these two have and uh yeah I I
was just going to say I like it Tanya I
love your predictions just uh that
enthusiasm about seeing a real fight in
this one and Magnus going for it big
move on the board D4 he drops it in and
now there's a big dilemma ahead for
Wesley if you take this Pawn you might
be hit in the center I'm not sure which
way Magnus intends to recapture either
he'll take on E5 with his own Pawn maybe
potentially with a knight uh but if you
take on D4 you're in for a bit of
suffering I was going to say oh this one
I'm reluctant to suggest because
suddenly if the Queens come off then
Black's Pawn structure the weaknesses
become more pronounced so Wesley I feel
has to keep the Queens on the board do
not trade you're facing the best end
game player of all time
I've even got magnus's book behind me
don't go into the end game he'll grind
you down so keep the queen on Queen to
H5 yeah this one is still roughly in the
balance but I don't like this little uh
this last couple of moves from Wesley so
I think now it is getting critical
already keep the Queens on best way to
keep your chances alive in this
m I need a t-shirt saying that Robert
that don't go into end games with Magnus
Carlson but I think in this particular
position Wesley will definitely not do
that
expecting him to try to slide over to
the king side Queen H5 get a knight on
G4 get a bishop on G4 try to play for
more Robert I'm keeping my optimism that
we're gonna still have a long game in
this one well I was first going to say
David is very humble because he co-wrote
that book he know had to grind like a
Grandmaster himself and then I'm
thinking this is the type of position
where the evaluation bar to the side of
our board here says now white maybe ever
so slightly better or it's equal but if
Wesley had traded the Queens I think
Magnus wins that position the majority
of the time double pawns are terrible to
defend when you don't have much time on
the clock especially double isolated
pawns because a Pawn's best friend is
another Pawn David if you could just
pick up the pawn on C6 for a second just
like hover with it and put it on B6 if
that pawn were on B6 then I'm like all
right this is just even not a big deal
because the pawns can defend one another
but with the pawns stacked the way they
are it means that this is a long-term
weakness that isn't going anywhere and
in particular the C7 Pawn if a bishop
safely goes out to F4 that C7 Pawn you
have to tie a rook down to it you don't
want to use a piece that is worth five
points in value to protect a piece
that's worth just one so I do think the
long-term chances are in White's favor
and that's why Wes is operating the
short term Queen H5 and as T you said a
bishop to G4 a knight to G4 use the open
E file you need to play dynamically to
compensate for your ruined queenside
Pawn
structure yeah super instructive there
and getting to the essence of the
position this is going through the
players mines as well that's pretty much
what Wesley was uh telling himself as he
made that decision he likes his end
games as well so the Temptation would
have been there trade Queens but then
you break it down then you think okay
it's all about the weaknesses you're
playing a great endgame expert you don't
want to suffer now at least it's not
oneway traffic and uh okay Bishop to G5
uh very testing move aiming to shatter
not just the queenside pawns which have
already been broken but also Black's
King side Bishop takes Knight a huge
strategic positional threat now needs to
be guarded against somehow but moving
the Knight there's not that many safe
squares for it do you Counterattack with
your black Bishop bring it out to G4
play a bit of mirroring copycat game
there you could aim to sh White's
kingside structure feels like this game
is really livened up just in the last
couple of moves um what comes to your
mind big threat on the board yeah after
this last move by Magnus my optimism
seems to be fading a little bit because
Bishop takes Knight and Wesley's got to
try to go on the defense with this I
really like the idea of jumping in with
the the with his own Bishop to G4 but
those trades and he does it Bishop G4
has been played but it looks like it
might just fizzle out with all the
upcoming trades white could just capture
on F6 white would take back on F3 and I
think at the end of all this sequence
you either take back on F3 U maybe we
can have the moves David and you can
help me out with it but even if you were
just to fall back with your Bishop to e
Bishop E5 is not possible because the
Rook takes on E5 and that would just
lose the game on the spot you think I
think you have to take on F3 here
Bishop H4 or does that run into Rook E4
there is no way to hide with the
bishop no way suddenly things would turn
around as you say Tanya otherwise white
would be loving life but unfortunately
this double attack just in time uh to
kick white off balance and uh just to
mention the other point you were
highlighting in this position black has
at very minimum a check hitting the
white king and now you can uh just take
these off and yes shattered pawns but
without Bishops without Knights far
harder to to attack these Pawn islands
and white not enjo exactly enjoying life
either with his structure so
everything's balanced here this is a
likely draw um this would actually be a
logical conclusion to the game Robert
this is exactly what seems to be
happening and if that's the case then a
draw will keep Magnus with a one-point
lead so I do trust Wesley at this stage
with the Queens coming off the board
maybe Magnus can work his endgame magic
but it does seem very likely a draw will
be the result so why don't we zoom out
of this game look at our other three
contests because with eight players in
this double elimination bracket I think
that there is a lot up for grabs as
Magnus he's in charge but some of the
other matches the favorites namely Yan
naami and alua they have not had a
steady first couple games and I look
second from the left right now yand pami
with white playing a close structure and
then I look all the way to the right
fedos sa against fuia it seems like
every time we look at their games they
are just like throwing axes at one
another they are not dodging a fight
yeah I think we should jump over there
fed against fua um because remember it
is 1-1 it's only been decisive games so
far and there's a big double attack on
the board black is actually a whole
piece up but this was intentional from
FV we see a double attack we see a fork
which piece has to move it's obviously
the queen here but where do you move her
how do you get into White's Camp White's
King a bit AR here and having pushed the
pawn to G4 I think fed will be feeling a
bit nervous uh
very logical move forcing white to
regain the material and white will
temporarily be a pawn up but it looks
like Black's ready to chip away at the
white Kings side structure um evaluation
Bar says 0.0 Tanya what's your vote
whose position would you choose I would
pick black all day every day here I'm
loving the activity The Rook can slide
into d8 your idea of H5 opening up the H
file looks extremely scary I could win a
Tempo inserting Rook to d8 if you go
Queen E2 The Rook will come to the
second rank as well with the tempo uh
meanwhile if the queen leaves the
connection with the F3 Square I'm might
to move Queen F3 I want to pick up your
H3 Pawn so some really tempting options
for black in this position and he goes
for H5 really like this David you
pointed it out I think the things are
getting very tricky for fedf he's the
one who's up a but he could be down a
king if he's not careful there's one
problem for black otherwise he might
already be winning if he could Castle
queenside then the game is pretty much
over it's uses your plan of Rook to d8
but it also gets your king to safety
while connecting your Rooks maybe you
double in the H file later but because
you cannot legally Castle through check
that does not allow fua to get his King
fully away from the center of the board
and if you play Rook d8 well your king
doesn't want to go to the short side
because you're trying to attack on that
flank so King G2 what a response from
feros of he's allowing the H file to
open Rook d8 still available and Bishop
takes E4 check becomes another option
that wasn't available a turn ago now you
can play it because because the check
against the white king but you may see
your own King Be In Harm's Way after a
series of Trades so this is a critical
moment for fuja if you don't take this
Pawn on e4 now maybe white will soon
play Pawn to F3 and try to keep the
extra pawns you need to play precise
chest from both sides here it's a messy
position but I would say that I think
black has a little bit more to prove
right
now I actually want to go back and just
mentioned Tanya's move Rook to d8 maybe
it was slightly more accurate to play on
the previous move because now this looks
so natural but white has the move Queen
to F3 if the Queens come off we talked
about it in the other game suddenly it
would clearly favor white not just upper
Pawn but this bishop will be locked out
the game and uh but due to the slightly
odd Pawn structure especially on the
queen side white would have a long-term
Advantage so uh if black had flick in
this move earlier this queen F3 idea was
not available he could pretty much have
that move for free white would have been
forced to choose a worst Square for
example one like this with the queen but
this would have allowed the black rook
in so sometimes move order is uh really
important here sudden black would have a
big big Advantage big attack on the
white king and instead this simply isn't
possible just to mention the other moves
after King to G2 Bishop takes E4 as
Robert pointed out this is committal you
win your Pawn back but at the cost of
giving up castling rights for good this
check and the black king sitting on f8
this is a lottery to me I don't know
whose King is weaker but the players
have to work that out as well so right
now big decision ahead for fua feels
like fed have maybe mixed up his opening
slightly but fua failing to punish him
so far still fine for black Robert
thinking more to prove for FIA I'm
inclined to agree um also Pon takes Pawn
white would take back with the queen if
the Queens disappear clearly white is
the one Inge um I'm loving the games
between these two I've got to say today
just really entertaining
chess we've had two decisive games
between these two players Ali are taking
the first win fedos here with black
pieces striking in the second one and
both complete roller coasters and this
one looks like it's going that way even
the position that you had on the
analysis board David with Black's King
on f8 White's King in the open as well
with the FG and H Pawn advanced in front
of him it's anyone's game and I think a
decisive result in this one is very
likely as well Robert what would be your
prediction do you think the players are
going to try and trade off the pieces
along the E file or we're going to get a
bit of a blood bath against each other's
King I think that we are going to get
that blood bath I mean there is no
hiding at this point and for fuja who is
well down on the clock the last thing he
wants to see is a queen trade so he
wants to play Pawn takes G4 but he sees
that the White Queen will just snack on
that pawn right back and white is a pawn
aead everything does look relatively
solid for him so fuja you could see that
he is not happy to be in this position
he thought that he would have easier
forms of compensation that there'd be a
direct path to regaining his Pawn
deficit but no it's not that clear
taking on e4 it does restore material
equality but the white king will be no
safer uh EXC the black king will be no
safer than the white with a check along
the eile I don't think that fer wants to
be in this position and Vladimir FV he
can make him pay with this lead on the
clock oh he spent so much time pretty
much half of his remaining time or more
on that one move eventually does regain
the pawn and uh we'll see Fed have
surely just get rid of that Bishop one
of the potential attackers of the white
king and that whole variation we showed
uh with the two kind of Airy Kings it's
just Mutual attacking despite the fact
that there are all these trades um in
the meantime um key position here but
let's briefly zoom out I just wanted to
do a quick Roundup the other games still
in a quieter uh kind of mood the other
players uh a draw between Vash gra and
lavic they really are racing towards the
Armageddon now I think that's the most
balanced match of the day um nothing to
choose between the two of them so far
the second game from your left Yan pomi
against Martinez very very symmetrical I
was say that NPI may be the slightly
happier of the two uh he has a better
Bishop Carson against Wesley so also
racing towards a draw so this is where
the action's happening Nomi against
Martinez and fev against fuja um I'm
going to vote that we quickly jump into
Nomi Martinez before coming back to see
how fev and FIA deal with the weaknesses
of their kings um so let's jump over
there and see whether yand pomi can
mount a comeback
my first instinct is correct so what do
we think Roberts is white slightly
better I say slightly because it's
tension packed uh npom nesi as he aims
to launch the comeback let's look at
that game because uh we saw another draw
between Maxim vasher lra and Dennis Laz
we apologize that we haven't looked at
those games but because there's been no
separation between those two players
very little room for excitement when
your players are playing nearly perfect
chess uh there it's not like you going
to be able to have a tactical finish to
the game so we look at this game on the
other hand well if a white knight could
get to D5 white is definitely in charge
if a black knight could get to D4 white
can actually snap a knight off there so
that knight from C7 is looking to
reroute and white doesn't have easy
access to D5 I look at the clock huge
lead for yand pomi in this position I do
feel like he should be slightly
preferred because his Bishop on E3
attacks pawns C5 and H6 the bishop on f8
it's a very defensive piece with no open
diagonals to work with so I would take
the open B file the dark Square Bishops
but I do like that rerouting of the
Knight for black so small pluses for
each side leads to a relatively equal
position the speed t with which Jose
coms playing he's always down on the
clock really early in these games but
somehow at the critical moments he
changes the tempo and suddenly an
immediate reaction hitting this loose
White Knight which was defended how
impressed are you just he seems to
always have a reply up his sleeve
something in store super impressive
right and especially the speed with
which he plays when he's down on seconds
and it's not just about the speed
because more important is the Precision
which he brings on with the speed he
goes for the most direct most
challenging options it's never about
neutralizing the position trying to
simplify it because this position itself
we see is really complicated it's going
to become more of a mess as the game
progresses the Black Knight I the D4
Square now but I do agree with your
initial feeling there David that white
with this bishop the black pawn stuck on
C5 on the color of White's Bishop long
term it just feels that white will have
that slight Edge now White's Knight
going towards D5 I do like Yan neam
nishi's position here I think josim has
a big defensive task ahead of him yeah
because if you ever capture a knight on
D5 that really helps out White's Pawn
structure I think strategically that
would be lost if you can imagine a black
knight going to f just to stop a knight
from getting to D5 so you see here comes
the White Knight Black's Knight can jump
in first a knight on D4 and a knight on
D5 they don't actually threaten anything
that's the good news uh so for both of
these players they're jockeying for
important squares but I I just don't see
where the knockout blow is and that's
why I'm looking at the clock I do like
Yan pal she's lead on time I think that
for josam there aren't and that's Jose
for everyone who doesn't know his online
username that for Jose Martinez it's not
like he has a four series of Trades that
liquidates board and allows him to inch
closer to the draw there's a lot of life
left in this position because you could
see the makings of an attack and wow
what a move that was Knight instead of
going to D4 goes F4 do not fall for it
don't take this Knight on F4 because
after e takes F4 David the queen on C3
is under attack as is the Knight on
E3 tactics Gore suddenly out of the blue
we're talking about a slow maneuvering
game not many variations to show but
this would be disastrous for white
immediately so do not touch this Knight
if we go back to the game Knight to F4
this was reacted to with a retreat a
really sad move from Nomi but an
important necessary evil to block out
this black black queen The Black Queen
if she could have done would have slid
nearer the white king and look how both
players such practical players you can
tell how experienced they are in Blitz
chest tucking their kings away safely to
bed just saying okay these kings are
safe they feel safe for them wle so with
his blanket right now and uh now it turn
becomes a bit more of a maneuvering game
yet again npom she begging for the
Queens to disappear because then the
white king will eternally be safe I
wouldn't be avoid kind of avoiding that
Queen trade actually if I were I think
taking that Queen off would have guided
him closer towards safety but keeping
the queen on maybe more ambitious this
is the only thing you got to make sure
her majesty here doesn't get trapped
she's hit but she had a safe square and
uh yeah this one's anyone's game so many
tactics suddenly popping out of the
woodwork uh this is a
pin don't know in terms of the momentum
of the game it feels like it's up and
down and both sides testing each other
KN back to D5 and just he's holding his
own with just 40 seconds left on the
clock he's aiming to jump in really
symmetrical really balanced chances but
it feels like at some point someone is
going to kind of press that chaos button
and I'm not sure whether this symmetry
is going to last for too much
longer I think Jose pressed that chaos
button when he made that move Knight to
F4 we've seen these last couple of moves
coming in with Tempo White's Knight has
landed on D5 now the bishop going back
to E1 has only retreated to go further
to C3 trying to line up on this diagonal
once the bishop lands on C3 you're also
eyeing the E5 Pawn uh meanwhile Jose's
Queen drops back he's touching the 302nd
mark eventually white Black's Knight has
to land on D4 Robert are we expecting
Knight D4 he goes H5 instead he's trying
to fix the problem piece that dark
Square Bishop it's staring into its own
pawns bad Bishops defend good pawns but
you want to create a good Bishop so H6
to the C1 diagonal that's some open
lines but I do like how this game has
been going for Yan nepi he's been
kicking Black's forces back now that the
Queens are off there's no active play
and Jose he is a fantastic resourceful
Defender but he likes activity now he is
saddled with defense the C5 Pawn the E5
pawn and the knight from E6 ever moves
watch out for Knight C7 to hit your
lonely A6 pawn it is slightly better for
white but for now Jose has everything
under
control routing his Bishop there 16
seconds on the clock the big question is
whether he kind of uh can hold his Nerf
uh history says that yes he can J spam
here but the black Bishop I think he's
just going to do what you said Robert
he's just going to sit on a defensive
square and he's going to hope that he
can build what we call a fortress just
no entry points for white sooner or
later white will need to open up a
second front he's trying to get in with
his Bishop now that is quickly swiftly
shut down white will need to open the
king side whether that's with a move
like Pawn to H4 maybe Pawn to G3 now
that jam has uh kind of blocked the dart
squares he'll need to open a second
front of attack it's like an army H
you're not getting anywhere on one side
your opponent's blocking you fighting
you off you have to open uh switch their
attentions to the other flank of the
board there's going to be a lot of
grinding in this end game as the knights
are jumping around but the pieces are
also jumping around on our other board
we're going to pull up our bird's eye
view of the remaining two games
meanwhile an update that Magnus Wesley
ended in a draw Maxim Dennis lavic ended
in a draw as well but look at that on
the right Al RZA versus fedos the Queens
are on the board the Rooks are on the
board a queen trade offered and we go
into aook PA end game is this going to
fizzle out into a draw it looks like it
I mean look at the pieces that remain
black is two pawns ahead on the right
hand side of her screen now make it one
but look at the B7 Pawn in The Rook site
the second Rook on E2 will jump forward
and well fu is giving up his Queen side
to go for the king side I think this was
a sensible decision and fedos he likely
just defend his Pawn so I'm looking from
left to right the evaluation bar is more
or less in the center in both these
games but they couldn't be more
different we have a minor piece end game
on the left and Rook end game on the
right David you're like to grind like a
grandmas which end game do you
prefer I think uh the one on the right
I've got to say I love this camera angle
we see all the action all the moves um I
think fed have against fuja is going to
fizzle out Rook games do have this
drawish tendency White's Rooks are
active enough and um fuja even if he
wins the pawn in front of the white king
I don't think that's going to get him
anywhere that one destined for a draw
the other one blocked maneuvering slow
still we call it an end game but uh it's
going to go on for a lot lot longer um I
still like npom nishi's chances I've got
to say I think he's the one trying to
make the magic happen ultimately it's
all about the clock as well five seconds
for Jose
Martinez he hold his Nerf I think both
should be draws with best play but
commentator's curse I don't want to
predict too early still a lot of life
left been amazing to see josam and his
control on his nerves as you say David
he's got nerv nerves of Steel we see the
C5 Pawn under attack with Just 4 seconds
the Knight has to jump to defend it but
the kind of positions he saved and
turned around with just seconds on the
clock has been so impressive impressive
in this uh event so far my question to
you right now is can white actually
double down on that C5 Pawn he does it
because the Black Knight on C6 is tied
down to defend the E5 pawn and now we
are seeing the pawn structure
change the structure change this game
has just ended in a draw between fed and
fuja just showing the final stag is
there so let's jump back to that game it
was blocked but no longer the whole
Queen side disappeared Tanya the black
pawns dropped for the white porns and
suddenly the black king active I see no
reason at all barrowing a miracle here
from Nishi for JM to sweat unless
there's a miracle Checkmate in the
middle of the board which it doesn't
look like there is he's walking living
life on the edge here that's what I was
looking at David though like the black
king only has F6 right now is that the
only available to it so if you could
give one check in a funny way that black
king could have been made it in the
center but of course you don't have
enough pieces remaining for
white this such a yo-yo position with
the checks because Black's King needs to
stay connected to the E4 Pawn white
needs an extra piece to deliver
Checkmate doesn't have it I think we're
going to see a repetition
here you see the draw both players lean
back npom she's smiling despite his
deficit Jose Martinez shaking his head
he knows that he lived life on the edge
yet again three games in a row he's been
living on the increment on the added
time I don't know how much longer that
can go on uh he does have white however
in the fourth and final game of uh kind
of the regular time here and uh I don't
know who looks the happier uh yand pishi
just always with his eyebrows ra raised
these days fi cannot be a happy man
right now he is trailing Jose Martinez
who has a one-point lead Yan pishi has
to win on demand a must win game four
coming up in that matchup as we see the
score line 2 to one Chim needs only a
draw to advance in the winners bracket
meanwhile Ali Rea fuja Vladimir fosier
with their first draw of the day in game
three it was a wild ride Wesley so
Magnus Carlson Wesley has to strike back
in the final rapid game meanwhile danis
lack he is
unbreakable with three draws against
Maxim Vash lra what was the stand moment
for you in this one
David in this round I've got to say it
was probably those end games uh
especially that game between fua and FV
um there were fireworks at the beginning
but ultimately both players just upping
their game just kind of pulling the
breakes and uh going into solid mode
towards the end um it was tough to call
though it felt like this was just the
players finding their balance kind of
saving energy for the fourth and final
game where some players now in must-win
situations and uh really needing to just
go all in throw everything at the
opponent Robert what are the chances of
us getting an
Armageddon extremely high have you seen
the match between Dennis lavic and Maxim
V the answer is no because they keep
drawing and Dennis lavic has shown that
his rating may be 2550 2560 but the way
he's performed on the biggest stages the
world rapid the world Blitz the CCT
finals he is well above 2650 level in
the quicker time controls so we see
Magnus on camera we don't see Wesley so
for a second game in row Wesley is
nowhere to be found when the games are
beginning in just a few seconds this is
the final game for Wesley has to win the
good news for Wesley and Wesley fans is
that he starts with the white pieces and
I want opening predictions David what's
Wesley going to start with in this
must-win game I don't know what he's
going to start with but I'll say he will
not start with 1 B3 we saw that too much
in Toronto in the tour finals uh last
year back in December um I think he's
going to start with E4 again he faced
the Kings Indian last time the Kings
Indian allows the opponent
chances but I'm wrong E4 instead and
what will Wesley do next okay what do
you think we'll see from here could
still be Italian Spanish you still got
options if he goes Bishop to B5 we're
seeing a Berlin is my prediction and
we've got an Italian we've got a game on
our hands Robert we do and often times
in these Italian quiet openings you can
just maneuver for a while but Magnus
Carlson he's really good at maneuvering
he doesn't mind exiting theoretical
Waters as quickly as possible but I do
like this choice right here Bishop to G5
because black often is encouraged to
push the G Pawn up two squares and we
saw in some very important games in the
Tata classical tournament it can get
scary for black if you have to extend
your kingside pawns too far castling
becomes more
difficult Magnus instead drops his
Bishop back black has actually lost a
move this black Bishop came out to C5
and then dropped back just a couple of
moves later to E7 so that's the
justification as Robert says it's always
scary you never want to touch a pawn
especially if you plan to Castle King
side especially if you only need a draw
uh so Magnus now I've got to say as well
his trademark move he never allows his
opponent to gain space on the flanks A4
he meets just every single time with A5
uh no matter kind of For Better or Worse
he will always block on the flanks and
Magnus as if he's hearing me Smiles
there sorry Magnus giving away your
secrets but yeah this one I'm expecting
actually Wesley to do a few funky things
maybe he'll drop his Bishop back in the
near future often white actually delays
uh what castling delays what we would
normally associate with the slower
Italian games he's there we go he
attacks the pawn and uh yeah it's just
about whether he comes forward with his
Knight now he comes to D2 instead maybe
we'll see a bit of dancing by both
players a bit of maneuvering but uh
shaping up nicely again cal before
what's guaranteed to be a
storm got to be a storm because wesle so
has got no option but to throw
everything that he's got at Magnus
Carlson in this one it starts slow right
now Wesley made the moves Pawn to C3
always eyeing the D4 Central break to
open things up at the right moment very
often Robert in these position black
wants to try to trade off the light
Square Bishop is Bishop B6 a move on
magnus's radar here it's on my radar
it's definitely on his radar and then
the question for Wesley is do I trade
right away do I allow black to take me
on C4 because I have a knight that can
capture back and the white Bishop can
also slide up the board to B5 just to
put a little pressure on the pony on C6
so there are options available to White
the D3 to D4 push is clearly what the
players will be looking for but for what
you don't want to rush that decision
because as soon as you push your D- Pawn
your E4 Pawn feels a little bit looser
so I would say the slight Advantage for
white is because of the quality of the
minor pieces in particular the bishop on
E7 it's a passive piece and the uh
Bishop on C4 for white already developed
the Black Knights completely restricted
especially the KN on C6 so I would say
those are the small little pluses here
but it's not much and Magnus he's very
solid and he has a lot of experience
from the black side of these
setups and I want to mention we saw a
feature chat appear briefly saying only
Wesley would play the Italian in a
must-win uh must-win situation must-win
game and that might have been true five
years ago 10 years ago but nowadays all
the top ground Masters play the Italian
if they want to win because this is one
of the only openings you guarantee
pretty much all the p is on the board
past move 15 past move 20 um so it's
just about building that tension it's
psychological you have so many options
at your disposal Magnus chooses to drop
his Knight back watch out for Magnus
shuffling his King out the way and then
unleashing the F Pawn potentially a bit
later since this bishop is a bit of a
Target but uh yeah the players they're
allowed to stamp their creativity I used
to play the Italian when I was a CH used
to get criticized for it by everyone my
coaches fellow players they were like do
you not understand chess it's so boring
but uh little did they know it would
become the most trendy opening uh pretty
much worldwide at all levels and I like
to see Wesley kind of play in this mood
delay castling as we predicted just uh
bringing his Knight to the center and uh
yeah what do you make are you as excited
as I am
Robert no the answer is a definitive
resounding absolutely not and I think
because Wesley's in a must-win position
he is going to try to maneuver before
castling just create a little bit of
confusion but if we talk about stylistic
play I mean if we can zoom out or a
bird's eye view because Wesley is not
the only person who needs to win this
game yand pomi needs to win and we see
second from the left he is the black
pieces the engine it will favor white in
a position like that again the second
board from the left hand side but it's
because yand palomi can't have a dry
position where we just trade pieces he
needs to keep things a bit uh ambiguous
not allow clear tension so you see the
difference uh of play When people's
backs are against the wall and they have
to
win and uh judging from this birde eye
view what catches your eye first I mean
uh we've talked about this game Magnus
Carson against Wesley we'll check back
in a bit later Nomi wow maybe we do have
to jump there because uh he's really
being provocative he's really forgoing
everything we're taught as youngsters um
Robert I think you called it that might
be the game of this at least early
stages and uh let's go over to it
question mark attached to this last move
by napon
but how does Jose punish it he's
actually up on the clock for once this
is a first today game review is to
objective he needs to win with the black
pieces that is his objective so it's a
question mark move when you look at the
evaluation bar but it's the way to play
for a win in order to create chaos you
have to take huge risks so yanami he's
doing that and for a change he's the one
who's down on the clock because he is
spending time to make sure that his
decisions are Justified and for Jose
he's playing s so Tanya I I know as soon
as I ask the question you're going to
say no way but would you ever play this
way from the black side when you need to
win and a draw is the equivalent to a
loss no way Jose is what I'm thinking
right now because G5 for me it's really
exciting to see you on the board as a
commentator but wait a second the black
king is not castled haven't completed
the development yet and the gepon moving
twice up the board uh it's something
that's really fun to watch very bra and
I think you're absolutely on point that
for yanomi it's a move made out of the
mat situation more than a move that he
wants to make but to me just looks like
White's the one who's going to create
the initiative and Jose goes for it with
blackking in the center he's eyeing up
opening up off the Eline he takes D6 was
a big threat Yanna pami immediately
captures it what are you going to
recapture with because to me David all
options are equally tempting but I would
say I want to pick it up with a d Pawn
right now or is G4 something that I need
to be careful about about certainly as
you indicate there Tanya you need to
hesitate you need to calculate a little
bit but ultimately I think the most
ambitious move is the best one taking
with the pawn let's show some moves it
does look like it walks into G4 and if
you were had to move this Knight
suddenly your Pawn in the center would
drop uh evaluation Bar says still pretty
good for white still good compensation
but at least your path to Victory is far
less clear luckily you don't have to
move pieces that are attacked you can
Counterattack and pawn to E6 would
simply be uh yeah devastating for black
it's a battering ram this Pawn hitting
the Knight hitting this pawn and if
black has the tarity to take on F3 then
uh I'm not even sure what you do next
but for uh example just to highlight one
checkmating pattern now you give a check
kick theing back and Bishop to G6 you're
going to make the kiss of death on F7 in
the near future um this would be
disastrous but also the logical
conclusion of this variation we're
showing uh if we go back to the game
position he's still hesitating no he he
has just taken this pawn and pawn to E6
is a killer threat a winning threat if
black tries to block one final comment
here suddenly you open up a new hole for
the White Knight to jump into this would
be a check a double attack a fork pretty
much game over at least at this level so
npom living life on the edge he needs to
and uh he's tried something a bit
special here he actually took on
F3 wow giving up the bishop pair
counterintuitive but he's hoping that
once the White Knight takes now he'll
play E6 and there's nothing no Knight no
horsey Pony that can jump into D6 yet at
least so still I'm going to say ugly for
black but he's alive and that's all Nish
she needs to do for now to keep his
chances alive in this
match me Robert it looks like he's
barely alive he's given up such a strong
Bishop on B7 the light squ Bishop
White's got the bishop there White's
fully developed that Bishop from D3 can
actually land on B5 I'm pinning on
Knight on D7 I want to go Rook D1 next
and win the game on the spot G6 G5 was
you know they say Brave and well super
risky is two sides of the same coin for
me G5 just turned out to be just a super
risk you're correct this G5 idea it was
clear what his intentions were he needed
to play for a win so he decided to
strike early but his King is in the
center White's King is tucked away and
look at this bishop B5 black has to
Castle queenside if you don't Castle
queenside the game is just over as white
will pile up pressure on the pin Knight
on D7 very quickly so cast and queen
side when you've already rided yourself
of the fan ketto light Square Bishop o
too many holes to speak of the White
Queen can jump into E4 the only thing
and I really mean the only thing that
black has quote unquote going for him is
that the E5 Pawn is tender and so if you
can't defend that pawn adequately maybe
black steals it but even if black were
to win that pawn I would still like
White's chances because the black king
will never ever be safe this looks bad
it is bad but Jan had to do
something I'm just surprised he
hesitated so long before castling quid
side that was as you say Robert the only
move the only way to justify what he'd
previously done and okay J that Jose uh
did look up did shake his head maybe he
just forgot that that was a legal move
it's easy to forget in chess especially
in such a weak flank vulnerable squares
all around especially on the light
squares um but now he does need to uh
kind of deliver Checkmate or somehow
keep an attack going because as you
mentioned as well this Pawn is going to
drop if black gets one or two more moves
if black gets Knight to E7 maybe Knight
to G6 and just takes this Pawn
everything's possible anything's
possible if white doesn't deliver
Checkmate so yes it's a bad position for
black yes we see the evaluation bar but
at least now he's kind of narrowed the
path he said yes the stakes are high
Checkmate me if you do you deserve to
win this match and progress in the
winners bracket if not I'll win your
pawn and I'm back it so uh interesting
strategy Mind Games here from
Nomi and it's a really fascinating
position right because we're talking
about white needing to find a way to
actually win as quickly but I was just
about to point out that can white play a
slow move like A4 because there's this
really fun line that can happen if black
was to go G4 you know E5 Pawn is the big
weakness in the position and he doesn't
and David I just wanted to highlight
that it could be because of the move
Queen to E4 and I don't know if the
tactics work out but the evalar doesn't
move so it seems like it does and the
point is after F3 and I'm going to ask
you to help me do I give a check on A8
or do I go further with a sacrifice Rook
takes Knight is so tempting and I think
it does work because after Rook D7 Rook
D7 Queen to A8 you give a check now only
move Queen B8 I pick up the Rook on
D7 and it should be game over should be
game over of course it never dies
continues but uh yeah the black king now
has to defend its Queen and here I'm uh
assuming that there are going to be
checkmating patterns if you just move
the bishop out the way you could
probably even throw it away and then
with a check bring the Rook into the
center this looks over love it Tanya and
watch out for that type of thing to kind
of consistently pop up that type of
pattern let's go back to the game uh
after Knight to E7 A5 he's trying to
just blow open the queen side and I
think he's keeping this trick up his
sleeve uh like you said he's trying to
wait for the black pawn to go to G4 then
Queen E4 is pretty much a double attack
so A5 he's playing really energetically
here Jose but he still needs to deliver
the killer blow and uh I think the P
he's doing the right thing he said a
he's Castle quein side now he just has
to take the material take this Pawn if
he can and just pray that there's no
Checkmate no knockout blow um four and a
half minutes for Jose Robert do you
think he's GNA find something how easy
is it to find something here for white
not not easy at all I mean you just said
Yan said a then he says B I will take
your Pawn thank you so much for it and
that also frees the B6 square up for a
black Knight if you need help defending
the Knight on E7 May jump into the D5
Square as well so I actually believe
that this position it's hard to prove
for white as a you know an audience
member as a spectator as a commentator
you look you say the evaluation bar is
really high up there White's in charge
the king is safe on G1 that black king
on C8 it looks like there's a lot of air
in front of it but the E5 Pawn that is a
long-term weakness it's overextended and
I don't see an easy way to defend it so
white needs to give up that pawn and go
for an attack but if you start rushing
for your attack let's say you play the
move Pawn to B4 just try to really blast
open that side of the board you have to
make sure that you will have the
knockout and actually somehow that move
is Justified the engine doesn't mind it
but I I I was trying to make the point
that like you can just really be
onedimensional tunneled on the attack
and you may drop all of your other Pawns
in the center but I guess B4 is real and
it's because the black king is onfe so I
was just trying to give a throwaway move
and yet that's how good White's position
is at the moment but I still TR truly
believe that it could go wrong if you're
not
careful and uh there we see uh just
below the board right now actually Nishi
has played two moves that have been
given a question mark but it's because
of the match situation is and yes he's
technically objectively made the
position worse but he's made it harder
for Jose Martinez to navigate these
choppy Waters and uh okay one more move
a couple more moves have been played
Bishop takes suddenly things are
balancing out a question mark from Jose
trading off pieces
and is this making his job easier in
terms of guiding it towards safety going
for the draw what is his plan here he
gives a check and after the Black Knight
blocks some more quick moves by the
players this one's really calmed down
but black is still temporarily at least
a pawn up another Pawn will drop I think
the pom is surviving this game but he
needs to win
um what do you think of these
developments I think the only way to
explain it is the Mad situation for Jos
spam a draw is what he needs to wrap it
up and he doesn't want to complicate to
the things doesn't want to complicate
things too much but that said he's
giving Yana pami the chances that he
needs I think jpam have to keep the
pressure going right now the big
question is he can't pick up the A5 Pawn
The Rook from A1 can slide on to D1 you
give a check but black skin can simply
fall back to see it it's one check how
are you continuing this initiative how
are you continuing the attack the one
idea I want to point out before I pass
the ball to you Robert to break it down
further is that White's Queen can
actually also think about infiltrating
from the other side of the board always
watch out from a future perspective the
queen landing on e4 or on C2 and
actually going into the eight seven
square to start targeting the pawns on
the Queen's side still a lot to fight
for for white but I feel he's made life
a bit easier for Yan Robert I love that
point about the White Queen it looks
well positioned but it looks even better
on a squore like H7 white could actually
strike this H6 G5 Pawn chain with a move
like H4 at some point but what I really
love the most is Jose's last move Knight
to D2 he's losing contact with the E5
Pawn but he is trying to improve the
location of his Knight that piece wasn't
doing much of anything on F3 he's giving
up a pawn because that A5 Pawn Knight C4
Knight takes A5 that looks available and
wow I think that Yan had to take he is
trying to liquidate a little bit because
if that Knight does leave C4 now after
the trade on A5 maybe B2 is loose but
you need to be really really careful
with this pin along the diagonal Rook d
one check coming your way white could
win a piece if Black's not careful and I
don't think there's enough material left
for Yan to have realistic winning
chances so I think Jose is doing
everything right I just want to point
out one trick you cannot take this
Knight it's given a question mark this
move it wasn't the best but uh just if
we go back one move Queen takes Knight
would have been a losing blunder not
because of Queen takes Queen but because
of a check the queen jumps out the way
with a check and a discovered attack
against the black queen and the Queen Is
Lost next move so Yan playing correctly
Bishop to D6 blocking and he checks
against his King and he lives to fight
another day but uh okay he keeps the
Queens on now jpam and still with great
chances of potentially punishing yanomi
for being greedy black living life on
the edge and wow I was going to say
let's zoom out but suddenly a blunder
attached to this last
move wa suddenly winning the evaluation
bars gone Sky High but what is The
Knockout blow Knight takes Bishop
removing a Defender perhap the black
queen is simply going to be kicked off
balance right now actually Black's
pieces fall like dominoes next move the
Rook comes no matter which piece you
take with and let's just show this the
queen is overworked she has to defend
her Knight she has to defend the pawn
but she's attacked and if she gives way
for example drops back to C7 then a
simple capture a check and a knock
skewer to
end's winning he's about to take this
Victory luckily the White Queen protects
her Rook as well so no back rank check
Matrix let's go back to the game
position Jos B is about to take this
Victory we saw Yan pishi just smile
again shake his head nothing to do this
was a disastrous
move hii knows that this is over and we
could see it on him he's paused he's
Frozen Robert it's like Jose has used
the freezing spell on Yan right now with
that last move the C5 Pawn is about to
fall everything's falling apart moral of
the story do not keep your king in the
Center and play G6 to G5 it invited too
much long-term trouble for Yan and he
knows that his Road in the F in the
Winner's bracket comes to a stop it is
double elimination so there's still hope
for yanam Nishi well I thought you were
going to say the moral of the story is
that David spell is better than mine
because I said tornado and that's what
yand pomi did in this game and then as
you said josam uses freeze and it seems
like yand pomi has made his move no
longer Frozen but Rook D1 check Bishop
takes C5 coming it just seems like
material will be one for the white side
and all he needs a draw so he doesn't
need to win this game if he can force a
draw any moment he should do just that
so josam you could see him he was
bopping his head he's feeling the Rhythm
he's winning this match and this wins
King this wins King of the Hill but not
usually chess
games oh my favorite variant robt where
you win if you get your king to one of
these four Central squares quicker than
the opponent but yeah normally in real
chess you get checkmated and uh do not
take this Pawn right now you will get M
on the spot the White Queen will
recapture on F4 and the black king would
be trapped so you have to flee you have
to run King to F5 but surely there's
going to be a knockout blow in the near
future a check maybe we'll see your idea
Tanya that you predicted miles in the
future uh you could check come into H7
this black king get trapped within the
next few moves surely no way you survive
out in the open like this he's just
taken on G5 and once a black captures
recaptures on G5 then all these ideas
come into play you could start with Rook
to F1 eventually the queen can come to
E4 as well if Black's King Falls to G6
this king is not going to survive in the
center of this hill at all and yishi
he's just thinking does he even play on
in this position and if so what is going
to be his next move because it looks
like it might be his last one the king
is dying on that Hill it's not getting
anywhere uh it can Retreat to G6 at some
point but C5 can fall and I think the
attack is very clear so Yap poni he
hasn't made his move I think he
understands that this match is his
opponent and so he just maybe just
prolonging the inevitable at this point
as it's going to be a match victory for
Jose Martinez the Peruvian star proving
once again that he can handle even the
best players in the world in these uh
short matches not that many games don't
count him out ever he is really
exceptional it so good in these
formats just incredible play right even
in this game he needed only a draw but
then he goes He seizes the opportunity
to go E5 blows open the queen side after
the castle with A4 A5 really nicely
played attack and now he's putting the
finishing touches to the game so Black's
King on E5 is actually just trapped
there it's got no squares all you need
is to deliver one check where is that
check coming from he just fall back with
the bishop to F2 and going Bishop G3
goes Queen F2 another idea and that's it
Yi
resigns Jose Martinez is on a roll he
gets the job done in the winners
quarterfinals he puts Yan pishi in the
losers bracket what a day of Chess it's
been for him what a match it's been
taking the first game and the final game
wrapping it up he did not need to go
into the Armageddon fantastic play and
he stays in the winners
bracket in the meantime though we do
have other games Ono Let's uh jump over
to see okay it's just finished the other
man in the must-win situation was Wesley
so but ultimately wasn't successful a
draw just agreed by repetition Magnus
Carlson progressing in that one um so
Wesley tried tried 57 moves but it
wasn't enough Magnus shutting the door
on any potential comeback so we have two
players progressing lavic against Vash
gra on the far left we haven't covered
much but will get to cover due to that
Armageddon incoming and that leaves fuja
against fed and we know all about those
two fighters evaluation B on white side
in the remaining game but looks like a
mess looks complicated um a quick count
shows though Robert that white is a pawn
up how easy do you think this is to
convert for FIA uh not easy at all and I
couldn't even count the material I
thought for a second someone was an
exchange up but that's because there's a
white Rook on A6 like it's out in the
wilderness but it's also keeping Black's
pieces at Bay the G5 Pawn sticks out
Whit's Knights they're both towards the
rim but they're putting immediate
pressure on the C5 Pawn which cannot be
captured right away because the Rook on
E1 is loose so there a lot of tactics
and handing black a pass Pawn that would
seem scary to me but it looks like fua
he has everything under control the
engine agrees with his
choice it looks like black is about to
lose a pawn in this position David you
fall back with the Knight White trades
the rook and you'll either end up losing
the C6
spawn saying that is Knight C3 the idea
behind this move is f do he have going
to go in with that Knight further on the
board I think you called it t you have
to just uh be ambitious here you cannot
Retreat as soon as you start retreating
things will not go your way you lose
momentum so jumping in with the Knight
hoping to uh kind of recapture on C3 and
create this monstrous pass Pawn um I was
gonna say really nice simplification
here by fuia making the equation easier
to work out but suddenly Knight C5 that
was flashy the white Rook on E1 was
undefended so there was a trade and he
gets back with his Knight but uh is
flashy necessarily good this Pawn will
be blocked by White Knight on the D2
Square so Black's big Ace up his sleeve
is the D Pawn suddenly it's not so clear
the black Rook might come in watch out
for the white king no Defenders around
it and the evaluation bar
sliding wow could we see a turnar around
wh's two pawns up but Black's pieces are
so active yeah I think you could push
Pawn to D3 to force the White Knight
back and now Rook E8 because Rook e 2 is
a Tempo shot oh Rook B8 similar idea but
the engine doesn't seem to love it so
it's given a question mark maybe it's
because ah the Knight drops back
blocking the file and protecting the
other Knight now it's a Tempo too slow
so I think David that was a missed
opportunity from fedos and now look at
fua he has everything under
control breing through he's going to win
this G pawn and from the G5 Square
whites Rook does a sterling job of
Defending its own Pawn on G2 now white
is three whole pawns to the good and uh
this Pawn is held under lock and key
blacks D Pawn so close to touchdown but
not close enough the white Knights do a
great job of Defending each other and
blockading knights are the best
blockaders and now Loose as well it's
all gone wrong for FV after we joined it
he had such good compensation fuja
though fantastic technique and uh it
feels like he's just putting the
finishing touches on now the white pawns
will start marching as long as you don't
get checkmated you're winning this
game pter C5 7 Seconds against 22 how
big a factor do we think is the
clock that's his only hope for fedos he
has to try to keep the pressure on try
to find tricks with the Knight and the
Rook combined alira fuja marches up with
his own King delivering a check the C
Pawn can move forward now also defending
the Rook he falls back allowing a pawn
capture on G2 coming in with a check so
some counterplay going on here The Rook
can go to E5 now there are all kinds of
checks happening on the board this might
not be over yet no look at the
evaluation bar it's now even because
that white king it's hiding Behind Enemy
Lines It Might Get checkmated Behind
Enemy Lines so watch out for Knight E6
check Knight H5 check I think right now
you can continue maneuvering this night
around but white is two pawns ahead so
if there is no Checkmate you need to be
careful so I guess feda just stealing
Pawns in the process David do you
actually think that black could be the
side for Choice definitely and look how
focused fed is right now he senses an
opportunity the white king just marched
too far in again King of the Hill active
Kings you got to be really careful about
and suddenly Black's promoting this Pawn
black is pushing you have to be really
careful White's going for checkmate
suddenly who's who's winning this race
it's a pure Race White can he give a
petrol check if not black promotes and
wins Rook to D7 a blunder black deflects
the rook and wins a new Queen get to
appear oh my gosh what a find by fedos
Sav and he wins the game is over fedos
Sav takes it what a defensive find by
him what a Miss by Ala fuja Rook to F7
the big resource the Big Move by the big
fish and that gets him back in the match
as he wins his fourth game leveling the
score alira fuja so close this is a
heartbreaking moment for alira and he's
got to fight it out now in the
armagedon oh ala fua actually goes down
to the losers bracket uh what a game
that was just letting it slip from the
uh from the brink of Victory there three
points to the good fed what a comeback
and uh yeah we also see the other
results there Tanya um so many twists
and turns in this first day of
quarterfinals yeah we saw right Robert
sorry Robert just wanted to correct
myself s but ala fuja actually from
winning the match now loses and goes
down to the losers bracket as you
pointed out but we do have one
Armageddon coming up we do just Dennis
laik against Maxim Vash four draws that
was a very even match the other was
Topsy Turvy Magnus had things under
control after his win but between fos
and fua it seemed like that match could
have gone anyone's way but the last
mistake is the critical one and Ali Raza
fua he goes down to the losers bracket
fosa remains in the winners as does Jose
Martinez maybe the most impressive
performer in the
quarterfinals and uh I just wanted to
highlight that moment and do a bit of a
deep dive into where it all went wrong
for Alara fuja he'd already let the
advantage slip he had a three-point
Advantage but now the white king simply
getting chased to its Doom uh we saw the
white king now step even further into
the enemy camp he should have run to
safety supporting his own pawns run to
the Queen side that was the only way to
keep this game under control instead he
marched forward and a few moves later we
already saw white find the only move to
avoid Checkmate Knight E6 is a
checkmating pattern the white king uh
would have been doomed here but if we
fast forward the next few moves we saw a
few twists and turns a few checks here
and there but it was now once the
blockada of this black dewn disappeared
that fua uh lost even more control he
went for a Counterattack against the
black king But ultimately missing in
this position the only way to draw it
was difficult he could have given a KN
check and if black wants to win then
King to A7 the only move and uh here you
can give a few checks but more
importantly you can play Rook to D7
x-ray vision defending this square if
black makes a new Queen you check and
you win this queen next if however
instead black tries the same trick Rook
to F7 deflection as we soon see in the
game then the White Knight is within
touching distance of guarding this
Square actually maybe first a bit of a
finesse here maybe you need to actually
just move move the white king out the
way the Rook still protected instead he
missed this very difficult undertime
pressure under duress Rook to D7 instead
and beautiful double exclamation mark
deflection simply the white Rook
disappears no Guardian no bodyguard of
the black Dort anymore black makes a new
Queen and fed won the
quarterfinal wow so sharp by fed sa
right there and alira fuja he took the
lead in the match but it's fev who
advances in the winnner bracket we've
got a big Armageddon coming up between
Maxim V lra and Dennis lazic as the
players fight to get to the top of the
chel Masters but don't go anywhere in
the break because during the break for
all of you we've got a special video
coming up with Kristoff seel sel's
impressive rise to the top don't go
[Music]
anywhere
I used to work at the bank from 7 to6 I
was a stock market analyst I always had
an interest in this working on under
time
pressure and at that time I had a friend
it was Kristoff seli who was also
working at the bank during our lunch
times we often walked through the park
and and played chess as well I thought
one time well Kristoph you're you're so
good in explaining all this stuff why
don't you just record it you know make
make a video or something and maybe
other people can can listen to it as
well yeah and it all started from there
at the time I found YouTube which was
pretty new in 2011 and I uploaded my
first video on my chess explained
Channel and it was funny because I sent
Mich the video links so that he could
watch and give me feedback but all of a
sudden dozens of people
[Music]
watched later on when the channel was
larger I got plenty of people contacting
me about lessons and then I started
teaching yeah so the the channel was
really kind of the the beginning of
thinking about Chess as a career and I
quickly had a a full schedule like
basically teaching 30 hours a
week chess is such a beautiful and and
kind of multifaceted game and you find
something new every day in chess
openings in particular which is my my
forte I'm thrilled to find new ideas
present them to the audience and yet
help them to play a better and
entertaining ch
chess totally fascinating if you talk
with Kristoff about Chess in general but
also specially openings he's like a
machine a Fountain of
Knowledge I I was always fascinated by
the opening phase of the game because I
think due to this fixed starting
position you have something very um it's
very explorable you have a very constant
thing that you can look at
yeah I think my my total highlight of my
career with with with chess and with
with chessable um that happened in 20120
when pretty much out of the blue I got
this offer to work together with Peter
hin and Ne and Magnus Carson's Chief
trainer and second to write a course
about Magnus called the Magnus touch
about Magnus great ability in end games
in Middle games planning like all his
best games and ideas and I wrote that
together with Peter H was was a great
experience we were on yeah plenty of
Zoom calls that was in the height of the
pandemic it's pretty pretty
wild at the end Magnus recorded the
whole thing yeah based on my my script
which was
fascinating a real great experience to
get in touch with like the highest level
of Chess which was completely
unimaginable before I never thought that
something like that could
happen it's just a a wild journey in
away uploading a video in July 2011 and
from going there to their cooperation
with with Camp Magnus and then finally
last year in 2022 I won this author of
the year for chessel after having
successful courses in the past couple of
years it was just like impossible to
imagine when I just started doing like a
single video for my friend basically and
then at the end this whole thing
transpired it's just really unbelievable
[Music]
oh
welcome to the most exciting format in
chess
Armageddon the ultimate tiebreaker
Armageddon grants white more time on the
clock but in return white must win a
draw secures black the match win white
starts with 10 minutes and each player
submits a confidential bid within a of
time they are willing to start
with lowest bid gets to choose their
color usually black in those coveted
draw ODS let the Armageddon
[Music]
commence it's the most destructive
format in chz and is actually called the
Armageddon and the bids are in by the
players and look at that Dennis lawick
out bit outsmart Maxim V lrab by three
seconds Dennis lawick wins the
Armageddon bid 6 minutes to 40 seconds
Maxim b b 6 minutes to 43 seconds David
what do you make of this bid has Dennis
lovic managed to get into Maxim's head
it does certainly look that way first
off uh we should mention it's a
different format last season they had 15
minutes base time this year it's going
to be even faster but it definitely
feels like Dennis full of confidence
having avoided defeat in regular time
today those four games he was never
really in trouble he's backing himself
here to draw with black who cares if
it's a few extra minutes for the
opponent and uh I love that attitude um
as you say Tanya it feels like pressures
definitely on Vash the grav now needing
to win with white needing to find
something a bit different from uh the
games earlier
today and Robert it's a similar story
line to the champion Chester finals in
Toronto in the round robin stages where
Dennis laic Maxim VRA playing against
each other two draws and finally Dennis
took the win in the Armageddon there he
had the white pieces is this something
that's going on in the players Minds
right now what happened just two months
ago a must play in their minds because
Maxim Vash gra that was a disappointing
result for him in an underwhelming
performance so for maxim he wants to get
the job done here but Dennis he is shown
that why should he lose any game even
against the super Grand Masters he beat
Hikaru two to nothing he then took down
Anish giri now he's going toe totoe
every bit Maxim vra's equal in this
specific match so there is limited time
on his clock but he's shown that his
moves they are great and even under the
duress of time trouble he has proven in
his bullet chest prowess that he can
handle
it and this is the first time we've got
the base time as 10 minutes in the
Champions Chester what do you think
about about those Dynamics starting with
6 minutes and 40 seconds has Dennis laic
is this bit too low the games are off
what do you think about 6 minutes 40
seconds before we get into the
opening we're going to find out Tanya
this is one of the first times this
season we've uh seen this type of
dynamic and um yeah six minutes it might
not sound like much but the top players
they play bullet games all the time
Dennis laic so experienced and look at
this Central mess all the tension there
temporarily all the knights were St ing
off at each other in the middle of the
board suddenly they all disappear in the
blink of an eye and still a three and a
half minute time Advantage for Vash gra
so this is a branch of the English
opening earlier uh in their clashes in
regular time we saw the Spanish the
Berlin lots of really KY slow stoy stuff
now Vash gra going direct this Central
strategy and uh he's got a hope that he
captures AIC off guard Robert who are
you favoring it's early days but who do
you think is going to be happy with the
outcome of the opening well the
evaluation bar the engine to the left
hand side of the board is happy with
Black's play but I think that Maxim he
should also be happy because this isn't
a symmetrical Pawn structure white has
two Central pawns the D and the E pawns
black has only one and I do love
Dennis's last move Queen F6 he does not
wants to give white the entire Center if
there is a trade on D4 then it's two
versus zero in the center but black has
an extra two pawns on the queen side so
this is what we're going to be talking
about that's the Dynamics of this
position is that the pawn structure is
not the same for each Sid they're
playing for different
ideas and before the game started we
were talking about the matchup in
Toronto which was a while back but
perhaps Maxim is also thinking about
what happened yesterday Dennis laic took
down Anish giri in an Armageddon in a
very convincing manner gave no chances
at all and I think if my memory says me
right that is was black in that game it
ended in a draw and thenis took the
match he made it look easy and right now
I do like the fact that the pieces the
minor piece said it's all symmetrical
right now yes the pawn structure it does
provide some play for Maxine but to me
it looks like it's not going to be
enough it's just a position that's easy
to play and with black you just need a
draw to win the
armagedon and as you can see that
experience you can tell that he's played
a bunch of Armageddon just the way he's
handling it he still spent less than one
minute on the clock to get this far into
the game we it move 20 now Bishops
disappear as well he's getting closer to
safety and okay he makes this
controversial decision though that
Robert highlighted earlier he's allowing
bashra to just take this Pawn off the
board and I think correctly taking with
the pawn towards the center yes Black's
pieces are active the queen The Rook on
the open file the white Bishop is a bit
stuck on the E3 square but ultimately
now uh even if the Queens disappear
Rooks disappear Bishops off the board
there is this imbalance long term so um
I like what Dennis is doing especially
this last move throwing pawns down the
board now super quick play but Vash grav
he's got to be banking on his chances
long term and um yeah as long as he
keeps that two and a half minute two
minute time Advantage I think it might
come down to a scramble uh as you said
Tanya a draw is enough for Dennis but
still a while to go before that Queen's
cominging off the board as well wow
surprising decision Rob I love the way
that both of these two are playing
because Queen B5 had a hidden threat
that if the black queen didn't Escape
there was a bishop G5 with a skewer so
now the Queens are off the board that
should make it easier for white to push
the pawns if this E2 Pawn we're on E
four then we'd start feeling a little
bit more confident about White's chances
but look at Dennis his last move Rook to
E7 it's clear he wants to double Rooks
and prevent white from pushing forward
in the center but now he's also pressing
forward himself on the king side these
are players who are playing on both
sides of the board they're not just
tunned in the center I think that black
is stable the question now becomes can
white make any inroads Tanya do you see
anything here that would lead you to
believe that white can in fact make
progress I I don't know about White's
progress but the last few moves by
Dennis Robert to me it seems he's the
one who's looking for Progress he's
expanded on the king side he wants to
make the move H5 to H4 next try and open
up the hline looking for chances of The
Rook infiltrating with Rook H1 maybe
trading off more pieces on the board in
general when it's the Armageddon when
you're fighting for a draw when you're
low on the clock with black having
managed to trade off so many pieces I
think so far it's been s success for
Dennis
laic been a lazza victory this last few
moves uh at least in terms of the
psychological battle Black's King as
well has a clear path towards the center
just blocked off and wow Dennis creating
threats along the background but watch
out for White's threat white is now
threatening in the near future to take
this Pawn on B6 and undermine the black
Bishop on D6 hence why it's protected
and uh yeah I was thinking about what
pieces need to disappear I think why
wouldn't mind the Bishops disappearing
being traded off and uh black would love
the Rooks to disappear because then the
B Pawn will run so still very very tense
both sides with a lot to play for but
I'm looking at the clock still five
minutes Dennis is so Speedy uh just
another level so quick here he's making
Armageddon look uh like a classical game
he's just enjoying this moment and he's
playing against Max V the 2021 bu BL
Champion one of the biggest speed chess
Specialists of modern chess and he just
keeps the game going and the clock under
control I have to ask Rob Robert a
question here is F5 ever a move you want
to make in these positions to try to get
rid of as many pawns on the board it
absolutely is a move that will be
justified and is a good decision uh from
a practical standpoint does it create
some risk I think the answer is also yes
so F5 I love it I think the engine will
approve but for Dennis lazic does he
need to do anything unlike spell chess
he can just sit here and just kind of
hang out right you know he doesn't have
to use freeze he doesn't have to do
anything special but he actually did
just move his Bishop in the center and
that move it changed the evaluation a
little bit but black is no worse all he
needs is a draw he's piling up on the D5
Pawn actually what can you do as white
isn't that pawn just
dropping this might spell the end
talking of spells it might spell the end
for Vash grav in the Winner's bracket
he's trying to desperately trade off
Bishops now but Dennis I think your
sport for choice just get rid of this
bishop take this Pawn off the board if
you want to be flashy you could have
taken the pawn as well uh that would
have led some tactics now all he needs
to do just trade off one set of Rooks
even if blacks two queen side pawns
disappear with the absence of both sets
of Rooks if it's just one set left easy
draw and uh why actually worry about
that when you can go for the
Counterattack Black's a whole Pawn up
and he's going to put his Rook on F7
defend everything I think Vash gra is
the one fighting for the draw here he's
having to take risks and look at the
march of these two connected passes
these two pawns together will will win
the game for lazic now or at least will
get him the desired
result
Maxim is down upon he's just got a one
minute lead on the clock flagging is
nowhere in the cards right now Dennis
lazovic in driver's seat he made it look
against an easy against Anish G he's
making it look easy against Maxim V lra
how does the kid do it Robert he's a
fantastic player he's just extremely
underrated and the top players they
don't take him lightly and we just saw
beat Hikaru and Anan he is not losing
this game to Maxim VRA all Dennis needs
is a draw he may in fact win this game
as Maxim has to go all out uh this
question mark I don't care about it I
think we can all agree to disagree with
the game review saying that yeah maybe
it's not the objective best move but all
black needs is a draw so to answer your
question Tanya is that Dennis is
underrated he's a great bullet player
he's exceptional speed chess player and
he can do it in Rapid even in the world
rapid championships he's shown that so
credit to him he is just an amazing
amazing player at just
so I wanted to say he has a superpower
and he knows how to use it he has a low
rating and this is for everyone out
there at home if you're playing someone
higher rated you can just play solid you
can bully them and uh use it against
them and there we see resignation Dennis
wins it and gets past Maxi V gra 17y old
Dennis lazik he gets the job done in the
Armageddon against Maxim VRA takes the
dub stays
the Winner's bracket goes through to the
winner semifinal he relegated harkar
Nakamura he relegated Anish G and now he
puts Maxim basher rra in the losers
bracket incredible Chess By Dennis he
really is a menace to the top
guys he is indeed that's why we call him
it is a loving nickname for him but he
is a menace and he will be for years to
come because Dennis lazic he continues
to prove why he made it through to the
champion chess tour finals just two
months ago now in Toronto is he can hang
with the best players he doesn't win
that many games let's be clear but he
can hang he can draw and when all you
need is a draw with the black pieces
against the super Grand Master he can do
it and he just
did that was absolute class by Dennis
and David it just felt like Maxim never
got a chance what was the highlight for
you in this impressive
Armageddon simply Dennis was in control
from move one I wanted to highlight one
moment where the maturity of Dennis
lazic play really sha through and this
is our game review we'll see some
exclamation marks we'll see some
question marks but remember Dennis
doesn't have to play the best moves he
just has to play the safest moves with a
draw being sufficient so Rook to D7 here
attacking White's Central Pawn and after
this tricky move Bishop to D4 Dennis did
not get Hasty he did not get tempted to
take this Pawn allowing some
complications here no doubt Vash gra
would have actually given not Material
sacrifice The Exchange but suddenly
black loses control suddenly yes it's
Bishop for Rook should favor black but
white has three connected pawns here and
actually white would have chances long
term this Pawn would drop in the near
future the black king not entirely safe
and suddenly white would uh open things
up to having three possible results um
so instead let's go back and see what he
did he actually just traded off the
Bishops first removing all risk and yes
this comes at the cost of a potential
extra Pawn but if White had taken this
Rook off the board we would have seen an
easily drawable end game Dennis lazic
again not to be underestimated he knows
exactly how the end games work he knows
what to aim for and ultimately he's a
hard man to beat and that got him
through this
match we've been talking about Dennis's
style one of his biggest Trends has been
his endgame play we saw it an against a
niche we saw today against Max in Russia
we're going to go into a Shar break but
don't go anywhere as we're going to be
joined by Dennis who just took down
Maxim in this thrilling battle we'll be
back with the winner of that match in
just a
[Music]
few
sh
hello V come B come so this is where the
magic happen happens and this is where
all the magic has already happened yes
that's a good way of putting it that's
my world
junior8 87 it's difficult to tell you
how many doors that open for me and uh
what uh what historical moment it was
and when I got back the chess
Oscars very nice these five of them of
the W five and there's one on top that
is the sixth one so since he had already
got five they didn't want to give him
the same trophy so they gave him a
trophy of a king with the world in his
hand this is anand's first ever mention
in a newspaper oh so this is his first
ever he was mentioned V Anand achieved a
national record by winning all the nine
rounds to notch a maximum of nine points
in the sub junior Championship but
imagine now TS ri's daughter a is part
of the West Bridge AR chess Academy I
mean it's so beautiful to see how you
know life comes around so World rapid
chess and mind Champion so this was nit
gave me this
nice why do I get the feeling that ARA
knows all the trophies and why you w
better than you remember it cuz I
cleaned the because it's true because
it's true
Bo did you have a favorite thank you so
much Anand I feel this is extra
motivation for all the youngsters this
opportunity to actually come here and
witness these achievements and spend
time with you in this stunning room
Anand Aruna thank you so much for
[Music]
this
yeah
which one's
you the pawn I like the
pawn the Knight the Knight can jump over
pieces oh you want me to say the Queen
the Queen's the strongest piece on the
board this one's you King The King sucks
you can only move one square you've got
to reassess your
chest Grandmaster Maurice Ashley
presents Jeremy silman's how to reassess
your chess now on chessable so go to
chess.com your chess and start
reassessing your chess
[Music]
today
oh
[Music]
I
a
[Music]
welcome back everyone we are being
joined by the boy of the moment I should
say right now Dennis laic after his big
win against Maxine B gra taking the
match in the Armageddon firstly a big
big congratulations uh Dennis on that
match it's been awesome to watch you in
the tour last year it was awesome to
watch you in the world rapid and Blitz
as well and now it's been awesome to
watch these last two days Dennis you've
taken down Anish giri Hikaru Nakamura
and today Maxim
VRA how are you feeling right now and
which one of these three has been the
most special win for
you yeah yes of course I I feel great of
course
to I mean every win was uh really
special for me because it's it's really
hard
to to to beat you know any top
players but yeah
after my my win against hikaro I I mean
I I got some additional strength
probably my cof confidence is improved a
little bit and then
I it was a little bit easy for me to to
play and Dennis you said during the
Champions chess tour finals in Toronto
that you felt it was easier for you to
play online but you know I right after
that event you went to the world rapid
in the world Blitz and once again had a
tremendous performance so uh you know
how do you keep doing it do you just
think you prefer quicker time controls
to classical chess what's your favorite
time control to
play
um actually I think my my favorite
control
is rapid I guess
because you know I think I a little bit
better play in Rapid but uh yeah
for in over the board chest
I in World rapid and blit I I played
better in bleed
and online I I played better in in Rapid
I think
because you know when I played title
Tuesday
I sometimes I played not so no not so
great but
now in Rapid I I think
I I played quite quite
good and uh Dennis after today's Victory
uh you progress to the winner semi-final
and tomorrow it looks like you'll play
against Jose Martinez another inform
player what do you uh predict for that
one how do you feel about your chances
in that
match I I think it uh it will be more or
less equal match I I didn't play play
against him a lot we played some
probably one rapid games and some bullet
match uh which
uh which he won but I mean it's of
course it U completely completely
different yeah I think
it's more or less more or less equal
mat Dennis we're really looking forward
to the fight in the winnner semifinals
and you mentioned that winning against
Hikaru gave you a lot of confidence
going ahead and we've got an interesting
chat question around that it's by yes
Senpai and he wants to know that when
you're playing against such experienced
opponents how do you manage to stay so
calm
I I already have some experience also
so all this uh
event last year um it helped it helped
me so I mean I
I just try to focus somehow
I online I already played quite a lot
against top players
so I mean
I probably
I you know I just
um somehow I I do it I I cannot explain
it but yeah I
I'm a professional chess player so I I
should do it
[Music]
somehow that Dennis it's funny I think
that makes perfect sense sometimes we
can't explain why things happen but you
know your pieces do all the talking and
we do have another chat question from
Indiana Rahul and uh they ask Dennis how
did you choose your Armageddon time
because you were so precise you did win
the Armageddon by just 3 seconds so how
did you decide on the time that you
bid um when I played against Anish I I
mean there is
a tournament in
Stanger
where where they they play armagedon
also
and the time is
like s and 10 I think and so it it feels
quite natural to to beat 7 minutes so I
think
he he
probably um wanted to play with black
and he probably thought that I I will
beat like 7 minutes that's why
I I beat
650 and now when I played against MV i i
s also
he
he wanted to play with black and he will
choose less
than
650 so I I decided to choose 6 6 and
14 I because also I I wanted to play
with
black and Dennis uh you're quickly
becoming one of my chess Idols but we
have a question from the chat from
Jeremy Q who is your chess Idol who's
your hero in
chess I mean
I I don't I don't have
any I mean I uh I like to watch
some some games of some top players in
in past and now but uh yeah I don't have
any Idol or
something well Dennis you may not have
an idol in chest but I see you probably
have a a good friend beside you is your
cat over there your little koska is is
your cat over
there um my my cat is sleeping in other
room
so well Dennis you said you don't have
any Idols or Heroes but you're
definitely taking them down one by one
uh in these events and Before I Let You
Go have to ask you all these medals
behind you so many of them Dennis and
I'm assuming that it's all from chess
tournaments um I can't count from here
but it's a lot any any special medal
amongst those behind
you
I I cannot choose
any I mean any medal so
it's it's like my my history so every
medal is important for me of
course that is a very deep answer Dennis
uh but also just like your chess very
deep thank you so much and
congratulations thanks for giving us
your time and tomorrow you've got a big
one coming up against uh Jose Martinez
in the winner semi-finals we wish you
all the
best thank you very much thank you see
you
Dennis 17y old Dennis lazic with a bit
of history behind him with all those
medals he's just starting to make his
legacy in the Chess World well has been
quite a performance for him in the last
two days taking down three of the
world's best players but the action
continues as we see on our bracket here
in the winner semi-final Dennis will
take on Jose Martinez Magnus Carlson
will take on Vladimir FV Robert two big
matchups coming up in the semi-finals
what's your take on this action well we
also have matches going on in the losers
bracket but you asked me what happens up
top so I'll keep my head up high and I
think that between Magnus Carlson and
Vladimir fedos we'll have players
swinging at one another and then of
course between Dennis lvic and Jose
Martinez we have a bit of a stylistic
clash but they both are quite solid in
nature and they love to get down to
their waning second so uh in the
Winner's bracket it will be interesting
chest for sure and the losers bracket
it's a fight to survival so David I
don't know which match is your favorite
because all of these feature are some
excellent very fan favorite players now
we're really spoiled for choice in the
losers bracket where the states are
higher than ever they cannot afford any
more match defeats um I'm going to say
npom nesi fash gra is going to be fire
on the board npom nesi we saw it today
not quite clicking into gear but I have
a feeling tomorrow he'll be desperate to
make a m so a lot to look forward
to I'm really excited excited about that
one as well David both players
disappointed with day one here in
division one we're going to see an angry
Yan and an angry Maxim Vash lra both on
their lost lives of course there are big
matchups all around in the winners
bracket as well it's been awesome it's
been amazing covering a division one
with both of you once again and of
course chat we will be back with day two
with the winners semifinals as well as
the losers bracket as two players will
be knocked out off Division One tomorrow
it's a goodbye from the three of us
we'll see you
[Music]
tomorrow
a
[Music]
sh
a
[Music]
to